help
spe
everyone welcome to the new
confines
um believe it or
not believe it or not this is what we
were all used to and it felt kind of
strange to have to holler across the
room um
it may seem tight but you'll get used to
it the only problem with this room and
it's not a problem yet but it may be um
is the noise Factor this is a this is a
slight removable wall it doesn't block
the noise so if there's a hearing on the
other side it's it does get loud in
these these narrow rooms but we should
be uh we should be good today Mr chair
are you concerned that we're going to be
Rowdy and create a
Ruckus please uh control yourself for a
moment all right um can we um please
first of the United
States and to the for stands one nation
God indivisible withy andice
for thank you um
quick couple of uh housekeeping issues
first um one is I wanted to make sure we
acknowledge and thank the work of our
vice chair in the last hearing that we
were all together um I did watch the
hearings um on YouTube a couple of times
and um I thought she did a tremendous
job so I appreciate your help um Madam
Vice chair um it won't won't be the last
time that I uh that I bail and let
uh um our work go and capable hands um
so thank you there uh secondly as far as
our work schedule on the exact session
today um I think what we're just so
everyone is um up to dat with where it's
going we have received some last minute
information on one of the bills um House
Bill 6 1866 we received and I think
everyone has received by email um an
amendment to that bill um rather
than processing uh through the exec
session I think what would be best is if
we uh put that exec session on that bill
off until the
31st um it appears like we are still
have time to be able to get it in the
calendar so um on the 30 1st you can you
will see that house bill 1666 will be
EXA on that day um and there was no
times listed so we're just going to uh I
think we've lumped them all together at
one o00 um so I think uh we'll we'll
it'll be in that batch somewhere along
the line I'm getting puzzle looks from a
couple people but uh we we should be
good for this for the 31st for 1666
great um that means we have this morning
uh 5 1 2 three four five bills to exec
um and then we have hearings this
afternoon
um and I've done it this way but I'm not
sure I'm going to continue to do it this
way with the exact session in the
morning and um and the hearings in the
the afternoon I think I think but I'm
open to suggestions from the committee I
think it works better if we do the
reverse if we have the hearings in the
morning and the exec session in the
afternoon it may not matter to anyone
else um I did it this
way this time because if you recall
there was some confusion over whether we
would be having a hearing uh I'm sorry a
house session today um
and I quickly put it in here thinking
that people would have already had this
day circled on their calendar and so it
would be a a great opportunity for us to
uh um probably have uh full attendance
of our committee as it happens it didn't
work because we have two um helpers
today two substitutes uh thank you very
much for attending and for helping us uh
with our work um rep ger Mana is that
how it's pronounced and rep PRI um so
thank you very much for uh for helping
us um but from from now on I'm going to
try to do everything I can um to do the
reverse and have the exact session in
the afternoon and hearings in the
morning we do want to uh try to get rid
of or not rid of bad choice of words we
do have um we do want to try to um
do do diligence on all of our bills um
as quickly as we can there the speaker
has already suggested that we plan to
have at least three sessions in um in
February hopefully we're not going to
have a session the last week of February
um which is also school vacation week
which is always kind of nice um but I
want people to understand that we have a
record number of bills for uh for the
second year of the session and and the
goal for me is to not have at crossover
an inordinate number of bills that we
have to go through so the quicker we can
get through our work here the quicker we
can handle those in February and the
quicker we don't have to worry about um
maybe meeting till 1 or two in the
morning um before crossover so that's my
goal um any anyone that has suggestions
on how we can accomplish that more
efficiently I'm I have two ears and I'm
happy to listen um great with that uh I
think I will open the exact session
on House Bill 1096 and uh recognize
representative
wall for a motion thank you Mr chairman
can you hear me um House Bill 1096 says
it's enabling the State House Visitor
Center to sell state symbols that may
have intellectual property rights I'd
like to just have a motion at okay I'll
make the motion you want that first
thank you um I move
itl rep W moves itl is there second
second I saw representative sell's hand
first uh second by representative
sellers um would the maker of the motion
like to speak on her motion I'll speak
very briefly Mr chairman uh we had
testimony uh from the prime sponsor that
he would prefer to have state songs
available through the visitor center uh
we had testimony from the director of
The Visitor Center Virginia Drew who
said we had tried that once before it
wasn't highly successful at all we have
lots of merchandise at the state visitor
center which um is constantly being
purchased and all and the perception at
the State House is that if you buy
something from the State House Visitor
Center it's sanctioned by the state and
that doesn't necessarily mean that if
there's a state song that the state has
approved of that and I would like to
hear from representative mcarter because
I think she has some really good
thoughts on this Mr
chairman thank you uh representative
wall I'll offer representative mcarter
if you have
comments thank you Mr chair thank you
representative wall um I just think what
what happens
when an artist or wh whomever uh would
utilize the state symbol which is
trademarked it gives a public perception
of whatever it is being sanctioned by uh
the state of New Hampshire it could be a
song it could be a piece of artw workk
it could be a flag it could be you know
anything if it portrays the state symbol
it gives a subliminal um uh message to
the general public that this is
something the state of New Hampshire is
supporting or encourages or what have
you um and and I just think that you
know that there's a lot of controversial
stuff out there that where this could go
could be certainly a lot of benign
things but I just really don't think
that it's a necessary um area for for
this to that we need legislation for
this I I I would vote itl on this as
well
thank you rep MCA uh any other
discussion representative wall thank you
the only thing I want to add to that and
I thank you very much um is that the
state seal can only be applied to
anything by the secretary of state so we
have to be very careful with that so
that we don't put the state seal on
things that should not have it thank you
thank you any further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role uh we are voting
1096 Madam clerk all right thank you
very much uh rep CH uh rep Sheen yes rep
sers yes rep costable yes clerk votes
yes rep Pearson yes rep mcarter yes rep
tney yes rep
wall yes representative nutting Wong yes
representative
sorry
representative representative
priest
yes representative ger yes
representative
montio yes representative P yes and
chair
unanimous
15 vote being 15 to Zer uh the bill will
be ited um rep
wall I would I would appreciate the um
well actually I think you've already
told me that uh rep marar will be
writing the blur um in that uh good time
for me to step in here um the good time
um for me to
say there's a new requirement or a a
plea on my part that um that committee
reports for me it's blurbs and it will
will always be blurbs um committee
reports will be due the day that uh we
hold the exec session
um yes I'd like to move consent um
calendar on that without objection
consent it
is W thank you very much Mr chairman
also um a practice we've had for some of
the members who aren't new here um it's
always helpful if we have a Republican
or Democrat who which party makes the
motion because we so often agree when we
come to terms on things it's nice to
have one party make the motion the other
party second it it it it's just a nice
way to present to the house that we get
along thank you well taken uh thank you
for your ah now we have a full house
which is uh beat beat three of a
kind um thank you very much uh that
would be on consent um House Bill 1066
we're going to restructure for just a
second and then we'll go on to House
Bill
okay I don't know where to put that but
here
all right um we will open the executive
session on house built
1309 um chair would recognize rep
mcarter for a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion of ought to pass on 1309 I
second it uh R mcarter uh moves ought to
pass on House Bill 1309 seconded by
representative wall representative
mcarter would you like to speak to your
motion I would thank you Mr chair uh
this bill HB 1309 requires that the
Secretary of State publish uh the
location of all enrolled bills and
resolutions on its public website this
uh will serve to facilitate more
transparency with uh and streamline the
process with regards to identifying
where the bills are um in the pipeline
and the movement throughout uh the
legislative process uh as was testified
uh to by the house clerk the creation of
um such an online portal will reduce
weight times and uh increase
accountability and also minimize staff
resources when inquiries are osed um
relative to the status of pending
legislation so I um would concur with
the house Clerk's testimony that this
should this ought to pass thank you
thank you very good off the top of your
head
um representative wall did you very much
Mr chairman thank you very much um yes
um the chairman of this committee has to
sign the bills just before they go to
the governor's office so again when if a
bill comes through here passes the house
goes to the Senate hearings passes the
Senate where does it go nobody knows and
for months a bill can be held up
somewhere out there and it's been really
confusing and especially when the
chairman of this committee is called to
sign bills where are the Bills and
there'll often be a stack of them but
nobody knows where they've been in the
meantime and it's really awkward if if
someone's coming in for a public signing
of a bill they they don't know when that
can Poss possibly happen because
governor's office can't say where it is
Chairman of this committee can't say
where it is no one knows where it is so
this bill is going to help clarify
things for the general public it's going
to make this process cleaner simpler
more understandable for everybody thank
you thank you representative wall I want
to be clear she's not meaning the
chairman of this committee has to uh
sign off on these bills um I am serving
on enrolled bills committee but um but
it doesn't come through this committee
is what I was being clear no it doesn't
but the as chairman I had to go into the
Secretary of State's office and sign
they always ask us whoever chairs to
sign those bills whether they're
enrolled bills or not they when the
final process is legislative
administration's in their signing at
least that's what they did to me thank
you I think you I think you were special
um at uh at any rate I will say um
quickly that uh the
problem um this is a solution that to a
problem that's been ongoing for years um
that uh it's very difficult with so many
parties um involved um it's been very
difficult for at anyone moment in time
to point to the point the finger to the
correct party that has the bill um and
this will help the public I'm certain if
uh to be able to know at least where the
bill exists in the timeline and um and
make sure that um maybe there be
pressure put to Bear to get them in a
timely fashion signed and and into law
so I think it's a wonderful idea um any
other further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to callor
roll we're voting on um House Bill
1309 so on 1309 the motion is ought to
pass yes um Vice chair Sheen yes
representative sers yes representative
costable yes the clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tiany yes representative
wall yes representative nutting Wong yes
representative turkot yes representative
Richards yes representative priest yes
representative J yes representative
montio representative peor yes and what
yes 16 yay zero
nay the vote being 16 to nothing House
Bill
1309 uh will'll go to the floor ought to
pass i' entertain a I'll make a motion
for consent or a vote to consent and
without objection seeing none it will go
consent uh next bill would be
1367 can you uh we'll hold for just a
minute while we reset sorry will we need
a report um yeah for that y um okay I
you okay go
ahead right we're going to open the
executive session on House
Bill
67 um and the chair would recognize ah
the chair would recognize uh
representative mcarter for a motion
thank you Mr chair I motion uh in
expedient to legislate
itl uh rep mcarter moves itl uh is there
a second seconded by uh representative
ning Wong uh representative mcarter
would you like to speak to your motion I
would thank you Mr chair
um hb1
1367 was a bill uh presented to Grant
immunity to people test in in public
hearing um for things that may otherwise
incriminate them in some sort of a
criminal activity I would guess um
however questions are still out there
that weren't answered as to whether or
not legislators have the authority to
Grant such immunity and I think those
questions are still out there um and for
that reason I think this is at this time
inexpedient to legislate thank you
representative mcarter um
I forget oh representative nutting Wong
you seconded would you like to sure um I
think that it is a I think it's really
well-intentioned but the bill itself
just isn't uh ready or um doesn't have
like quite the right wording for it
discussion I will just say um one
briefly that um there are a number of um
unanswered questions with this um the
biggest one for me is I'm not sure who
would look at any type of um um get out
of jail free card from um the chair or
any other member of um a legislative
committee as being anything that they
could use um aside from in Monopoly um
with any Court in in the land um I I I'm
not sure how that would would work um so
with that I agree with the I
motion with that I'll ask the clerk call
1367 all right so for House Bill 1367
the motion is itl vice chair Sheen yes
representative sers yes representative
costable rep uh clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative Tierney yes
representative wall yes representative
nutting Wong yes representative turot
yes representative
Richards yes representative priest yes
representative ger yes representative
montio yes representative payer yes and
how does the chair vote the chair would
agree and vote uh yes
okay 16 yay zero
nay vote being 16 to nothing um is there
any objection to
consent seeing none bill will be on
consent and the report will be written
by representative mcarter gonna be
busy she can have help um with that uh
we're going to move on to 1434 just a
reconfigure
okay we're back uh we're on House Bill
1434 relative to the honor and remember
flag um the chair would recognize
representative tyy for a motion motion
to itl the bill
representative tyranny moves itl on
House Bill 1434 is their
second
uh I actually saw representative nutting
Wong with her hand heading for the so I
uh would recognize nutting Wong uh for
concurrence um would representative
Tierney like to speak to his
motion even though the bill is well
intentioned none of the veterans and
organizations anywhere have backed this
motion I mean this uh flag uh in
addition to that it opens a Pandora's
Box if we approve one flag to be hung
over the state house then everybody else
can come in and say you did it for this
one why can't we have the same thing and
we will have flag from everything under
the sun trying to be flown over the
state house and that's the reason for
the itl
motion thank you representative tyrany
um is there any further discussion
representative wall thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee this
is a very sensitive issue obviously all
of us have had family member and Friends
who've been in Military and recognize
the importance of recognizing them even
after they've passed uh we heard just
testimony that even with this bill the
American flag would always drape the
casket of those who have passed or been
beside the uh n or whatever that holds
the ashes of someone who's
passed but there is a concern that this
was a commercial Enterprise to begin
with it started by one person who formed
a company it is a beautiful flag but
there's nothing to say we can't at our
homes or even in our communities fly the
flags we want but to say that the state
has to do it on certain days for certain
occasions following up on representative
attorney's testimony um is inappropriate
at this time the I did research on this
this bill has been before us five other
times and has failed for all the same
reasons that we've heard in terms of the
fact that it is a commercial effort even
though it's a beautiful flag um that
it's up to an individual or family or
whatever to do what they want with it
but to say the state has to fly it at
certain times over the State House
uh is not going to work so I thank you
very much and by the way it does fly at
the Veteran Cemetery and that is totally
appropriate for we recognize that in
honor of that thank
you thank you representative well uh
further
discussion so I would just like to say
um I too um feel the sensitivity of of
the issue um we all have feelings and uh
and for anyone that has lost a a service
member um this is a commercial operation
um you can go on their website at this
point in time and and order one of these
flags if it would provide your family
comfort um some of them actually come I
believe um personalized for the service
member uh directly um we did have
testimony from the Veteran Cemetery and
and that flag is being flown there um
the question was also asked about uh
whether it was part of the national flag
code and um in my understanding and and
research is that it's been attempted
since 2010 federally um to have it
adopted and uh and has died on the table
um they have a different system than we
do
um but it doesn't seem that nationally
it has the support um in order to be
part of the uh uh the flag code in the
same way that um our current flag our
current um US flag the pmia flag um is
part of that federal system and our
system um and we do have a problem um
beyond the the philosophical problem we
have a physical problem um the the flag
poles that we have on the State House
have difficulty uh with just the US flag
and the pmia flag on days of half Mass
um it's it's very close for the PW flag
to be actually not touching the the roof
of the state house so somewhere along
the line something has to happen with uh
with that circumstance but um but it
would be very difficult and there was
nothing in the legislation that I saw
that addressed what happens on those
days when this flag was supposed to be
flown that um that happened to be a half
Mass day um we we were left to try to um
leave it up to whoever is posting the
flags I guess I have no idea um
but at any rate um I
am lamenting somewhat that we weren't
able to do
something um I would I would recommend I
guess to the prime sponsor to uh to look
at the language of the of the bill and
perhaps resubmit um but I'm not sure
given our limitations and um the fact
that it's it's not been recognized by um
by flag military flag code at this point
that U I think it faces an uphill battle
so with that um being said uh no other
conversation that I can see um I'll ask
the clerk to call the rooll for itl on
1434 okay on 14 34 the motion is itl um
Vice chair Sheen yes representative
sers yes representative costable yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative mcarter yes
representative Tierney yes
representative wall yes representative
nutting W yes representative turot yes
representative Richards yes
representative priest yes representative
J yes representative Monti yes
representative P yes and uh
representative Hill chair votes
yes okay we have 16 again zero uh vote
is 16 to nothing um for itl uh seeing
no contradiction to consent is there any
objection seeing none uh bill will be on
consent and we'll take a few minutes
here to reset for House Bill
motion
all right we'll be opening the exact
session on House Bill 1495 making
Provisions for the P perspective of all
leg legislative acts on a sliding scale
based on the vote count when passed by
the House of
Representatives um I tend to call this
the automatic repeal bill um so I would
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to
move this motion hb1 1495
itl rep Hobson moves itl on 1495 is
there a
second
second representative nutting Wong made
me laugh did you see that did you see
her representative nutting Wong move uh
seconds the motion of itl uh
representative Hobson would you like to
speak to your motion sure um I I
completely understand and agree with the
intention of this measure to minimize
the number of duplicative and
ineffective laws on the the books um and
this this motion um we heard testimony
that it would ignore the other body um
as we are a bamal um body and unless a
constitutional amendment changes that uh
there's no fiscal note which we know uh
this measure would be um this measure
would be uh would require uh quite a bit
of work
um we also feel that any legislator can
add a sunset provision to their um
legislation going forward so for this
reason we are uh asking
for uh support for an itl motion
sorry nothing to be sorry about thank
you very much um representative Hobson
moves itl um representative nutting Wong
do you want to speak to your
second the clerk put it very very well I
agree thank you very much for that uh
any further discussion representative
wall thank you Mr chairman all I'll add
to it is we had strong testimony from
the house clerk that this would require
further uh Employments of staff there is
no fiscal not as you've heard on this
and there should be there must be if
we're going to be spending money uh
there's a question of constitu excuse me
constitutionality on this um is just
problematic all the way around thank
you thank you representative wall any
further
discussion I would just
say there was a discussion during
testimony that the idea was to reduce
down the number of bills um with this
and I failed to understand that point of
view I uh um I would see this as adding
to the number of bills that we would
have in a given year um I also am
concerned that there would be um
opportunity for um for lapses in um very
important laws that wouldn't be passed
or or wouldn't be on the books at the
time that they would be automatically
repealed prior to them being
reinstated um there was nothing in the
legislation that um for instance
Exempted criminal justice uh legislation
so um you know you can Envision a
circumstance where a a a very serious
crime um couldn't be charged because
there was nothing on the books at the
time because it had been um um
automatically repealed and hadn't been
reinstated as yet so um while it's an
interesting idea and I don't ever want
to squelch the possibility of
interesting ideas coming down the pike
but um but this one needed some serious
uh serious work much more so than
anything that the committee was um would
be capable with time and and duty to
actually accomplish uh yes
representative wall thank you Mr
chairman I I simply want to clarify for
some members who weren't here for
testimony and back up what you've said
the fact that the additional staff would
be a dedicated person just to follow
every single bill that ever gets passed
into law and that means that person
would have to follow each bill until the
fifth year comes when that bill then
becomes null and void it's almost an
impossible task and there are bills that
really should continue laws that should
continue forever does that mean we would
have to every five years resubmit a bill
for a law that works um it just is a
complicated problem thank you
thank you representative well um I
neglected to bring up the the second
part of the bill which was the um the
petition approach of requiring 100 um
signatures on a I don't think they use
the word petition but I will um on the
petition to create
um any existing bill would come up with
100 signatures would have to be um
rediscussed and and red debated and
revoted um I'm not sure the need for
that because it would seem to me and all
of us in this room
um have been witnessed uh or been
approached by a single member of the
public who have asked us to uh file
legislation um to
repeal any number of laws um and that's
done with one one just one person asking
us to do it uh so I'm not sure what the
the value is to having a 100 people do
it um or what would be accomplished by
having a 100 people asked to be um
repealing it bill so with that um if
there is no further discussion um I'll
ask the clerk to call a roll on House
itl thank you very much uh chair Sheen
yes rep sers yes rep coost yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes rep
mcarter yes representative tyy yes
representative wall yes representative
nutting Wong yes representative turot
yes representative Richards yes
representative priest yes representative
gero yes representative montio yes
representative payer yes and how does
the chair vote the chair votes yes
okay 16 yay zero nay uh with the vote 16
to nothing um I would ask uh unanimous
consent
on um consent calendar any problems with
that seeing none um host Bill 1495 will
go on the consent calendar itl
and um rep bson will write the report
blur um with that I think we're done the
exact session because as I said House
Bill
1666 um we are moving to the afternoon
exec session on January
31st um I want to make sure that
everyone um received the amendment that
um was has has been offered on House
Bill 1666 is that
it3 it even has holes for three ring
binder I'm going to keep one and go the
other way um yeah this is uh this is an
amendment uh that came up um from from
testimony so um I don't want to go any
further into that than that but
um but I would like you to consider it
and I would like to uh be able to talk
about it when we get to exec session um
in
um whatever it is two weeks a week next
week 13 uh
131 so with that I'm closing the exact
session and we
are going to have a nice long lunch
um it looks like uh we have almost two
hours before we would begin hearings
done
okay so the time being a little bit
after 1:00 um and this being legislative
Administration and recognizing the prime
sponsor for House Bill 1363 is in the
room we will open the hearing on House
Bill
1363 FN relative to allowing members of
the General Court to participate in the
Department of Health and Human Services
employee assistance
program and not recognize this Prime
sponsor Prime sponsor not up I have
listed here Prime sponsor Mar
representative
Smith
Bill well this says 1363 at: what does
that say what does this one say well I
don't
care yeah oh okay can I change your what
are you rerie Smith you wrote 1363 I
didn't write that somebody else must
put
okay and do I have a rep
A3 a prime sponsor do you have a pink
card for I didn't realize I needed to
fill one out as the prime sponsor but
I'll be happy to do that after my
testimony we don't do anything without a
pink card would you like me to do it now
is that what you're saying I would like
I would like to hear because I could
comply I would I would hopefully have
ask you to introduce yourself and um and
introduce your bill hope Bill 1000 all
right welcome to legislative
Administration it's my first time it's
very exciting anyway thank you thank you
so much so I am Francis Nutter upam um
Hillsboro 8 uh nashwa I'm a
psychotherapist mostly retired but I do
some gig work on weekends
workshops
um and other things um so this is my
sixth year as a
legislator and
um as legislators you know are we
employees or are we not employees it's
kind of a gray area you know we're
allowed to buy
insurance um if we need it I buy our our
dental plan you know and the rest of my
stuff is Medicare because I'm older um
but over the years my six six years in
the legislature uh I have been concerned
about some of my colleagues in the
legislature someone who's had a recent
bement um someone who has a child
suffering from drug addiction
um someone whose spouse is has a
gambling addiction and you know all
those kinds of things and I have
occasionally approached a fellow
legislator and say you know have you got
somebody to talk to uh do you have a
therapist you know and then there was an
incident I won't go into about a person
and and I asked them I said do you have
insurance like can you afford to pay a
counselor if if you needed one and ear I
thought they needed one and she goes
well yes yes I do but the employee
assistance program which many employers
offer is a wonderful referral program um
so any of those uh previous problems
that I listed they can hook you up with
someone right away and I made use at one
of my previous jobs more paid than this
one
um I was was having an issue I kind of
wanted to hash out with someone not a
family member so I made use of um they
connected me with a counselor and I was
approved for five sessions so and um Mr
Lawless in the back he'll be he runs the
program so he'll explain a little bit
more if you have more detailed questions
so right now if you were to try and get
uh an appointment with a counselor you
could be waiting months I hope you've
heard those stories or longer but
Employee Assistance programs has um
Professionals in many of these
professions sort of waiting for a
referral like they get top priority so
it was like seven years ago that I made
use of it and you know within a week I
got to see somebody and I I got to work
out my issue and so I just think the
stressors that we go through I mean the
public goes through it too but in the
six years that I've been here sometimes
people get death threats from
constituents or non-c constituents we go
through some heavy stuff we hear
heartbreaking testimony and I just think
um for the amount of sacrifice that we
make as legislators to be here that this
would be a very nice perk to offer
ourselves and our Senators the cost the
last page um gives a little bit of a
financial um analysis and it's pretty
cheap so and
um attorney Williams will speak a little
bit of the mechanics of that um but it
would be somewhere in like $40 a year
per person and the um
agency has assured me that they have the
capacity to handle our 400 legislators
and our 24 Senators I have um Mr Lawless
brought them today um Employee
Assistance programs some um pamphlets if
you'd like to look them over later I'll
I'll leave them here on the table and um
some larger pamphlets that explain so I
think this is needed that we feel that
um our legislators ourselves are getting
the support that we need and that we
have easy access to help when we need it
and I'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony
um you are willing to take questions in
light of the fact that we have experts
here um well yes um or sure so why don't
if I can't answer it then I'll call them
up so um actually I think I'll call them
up so so let's uh let's see how this
goes Sor I didn't mean to overstep no um
so um I that's my presentation and I
think the the nitty-gritty the two
gentlemen coming up will explain better
great so let's see hope you'll consider
this bill let's see if there are
questions first um are there any
questions for the prime
sponsor seeing none you're off the hook
thank you thank you very
much um I would like that pin card
however um and I
others do we have pink
cards are you are you willing to share
them with
be there it
is um so I
see one actually it looks like a
dual is this a dual presentation
oh boy um from Michael laws and John
Williams um asking for five minutes both
support the bill from DHHS and and
chairman Hill and members of the
legislative Administration committee my
name is John Williams I'm the director
of the New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services uh legislative
affairs and with me today joining me in
support of this very important uh
legislation HB 1363 is I'm Michael laws
I'm the director of the employee
assistance program and for judicial or I
should say legislative economy that's
why we're appearing here uh to be able
to present to you on this bill in
support of it um the department was
engaged by representative um Nutter upam
on this bill also with the co-sponsor uh
who's in the audience also right now uh
representative Joseph Pio but also note
that we have represent Pearson not
necessarily the Pearson that's on this
committee uh but the senior Mark Pearson
who's also a co-sponsor in this
legislation my involvement with this
bill happened early in the Autumn of
this year when our agency received the
confidential request from the
legislative budget Assistance Office to
conduct a financial review of this very
important bill that allowed me to to
match up with our wonderful program
folks here our director for the the
employee assistance program to get a
handle on what this program would do
from a financial perspective I know this
is a policy committee but at some point
and because I have the for former house
uh chair um behind me over here this
likely if it does pass your committee
will certainly work very collaboratively
with either division three which is the
Department of Health and Human Services
Division and whatever respective
division works on um legislative ad uh
legislative matters or legislative
Financial um matters so in working
through this the department contracts
out with um several if not All State
agencies looking at Mr Lawless confirm
that and as part of that arrangement we
enter into contract and that contract
with those agencies to provide these
Services which he will be explaining to
you these very uh very critical helpful
services to support our state employees
that we contract with each uh separate
state agency and we give them the exact
parody in other words the exact dollar
amount per person within that particular
agency that we' be potentially providing
services to so it's reflected in the
fiscal analysis that the legislative
budget assistance has done uh uh as part
of this bill and also uh what was
mentioned by the bill sponsor in in the
introduction that it we're looking at
around $40 plus per person for entering
to that contract as you'll see from the
financial analysis that the legislative
um Financial managers also were
contacted by the LBA and conducted their
analysis and it represented in here that
they they feel they can absorb or at
least it's stated that this can be
absorbed in their budget for purpos of
making this happen um I would represent
to you not at this realm but at the next
realm before the finance committee that
we just want to make sure that our
financial folks in our agency are
communicating with your financial folks
because if this is a good idea and you
agree that it's a good idea and it's not
a lot of money that we're talking about
and the legislature seems to have that
money we just have to make sure because
this is an interde departmental transfer
that our financial people are talking to
each other to make sure the language in
this bill is absolutely 100% either no
barriers or at least commensurate with
what they need for transferring the
language and I just raised that so that
you're not surprised if you see any
further amendments as this bill moves
along so as far as any questions
regarding like the fiscal piece of this
I'm going to turn it over to what really
is important which is the policy side of
the conversation and so with the um uh
keeping within less than five minutes
which is our goal I think we're about
three minutes right now I'll turn it
over to Mr Wallace thank you I'm hoping
I have the same kind of sense of time
management because I I I'm really
passionate about EAP and I really uh
appreciative for for this uh audience to
speak a little bit about the program
there's so much to say you know I'm
somebody who uh I'm really invested in
the idea of people having access to
resources and supports and challenging
stigma and and finding a way to uh
navigate the challenges that can show up
for any one of us in our journey you
know that's one of the things that we
try to impress upon folks in whatever
audience we're in is
that we're people too right regardless
of the station you hold you have family
members who may be dealing with things
you yourself may be dealing with things
you know we we see uh state employees be
struggling with housing insecurity food
insecurity anything that any uh other
citizen of the state may be accessing
resources around can directly impact any
one of us or our family members um so to
that point you know we serve all All
State agencies all state employees from
entry level positions up to the uh
commissioner level and uh it's a
confidential program we've been granted
uh confidentiality at the level of
attorney client so truly what's said
with us stays with us we're also
available to state employees uh members
of their household family members the
family member gets the same kind of
confidentiality that the state employee
would as well you know based on uh
language and the administrative rules
employees are allotted three hours per
year to access the agency should they
choose to or a voluntary program we're
also not kind of monitoring the uh
sometimes people will come for one
meeting or a phone session or remote
kind of connection sometimes it goes
beyond three sessions we're not
communicating back to their supervisors
their HR anyone really what's said with
us stays with us unless a releasees sign
so that some communication can occur by
the employee themselves we also travel
and meet folks out in the community if
that's a place that they would prefer to
meet our main office location is here in
conquer but we want folks regardless of
where they are in the state to have the
same access to us uh that anybody here
in conquer would have access to us and
so you know these these brochures really
start to paint the picture of Direct
Services that we may be able to kind of
provide folks a resource around the
program has been effect since 1985 it
started as a pilot program and has uh
grown considerably through the years and
I think that's based on the fact that we
have a great reputation around
confidentiality but also our
Partnerships in the community to make
sure that if somebody has a a need or
needs some support around an area it's
our job to help them connect with that
resource and we take that seriously you
know this is not a place where you're
making cold calls to try to find a
clinician if that's what you need that's
what your family member needs
we're we're we're bridging that Gap I'm
not going to refer I'm not going to give
a number and a name to anybody unless I
would go to that person myself or feel
comfortable with my family member going
to so we know about the person we refer
you to uh or family we've had a
relationship or or an Outreach call
contact with them we know they accept
the insurance that you have and we know
that they have availability in the their
schedule to bridge that Gap and really
the range of services we offer while
this is an individual uh pamphlet about
Individual Services this this is more
like a supervisor's kind of guide but I
think that's an important piece to the
equation too because the service
delivery system that we offer is very
robust so if anybody is familiar with
eaps some eaps you might call A 1 1800
number or number and talk to somebody
two states over we're citizens of the
state we're uh you know employees of the
state we live in the same neighborhoods
that folks may be accessing resources
and so we have that Personal Touch right
so it's not just the face Toof face in a
referral system a cold kind of referral
system we cover the the full range of
any issue that an employee might be
bringing into the workspace anything a
supervisor uh commissioner family member
anything that anybody might be dealing
with our job is to be present be
available and try to find them the
support and resources that they might
need to deal with that challenge Beyond
The Individual Services piece that we
offer we do trainings we do orientations
uh mediation if two folks are having a
hard time kind of meeting in the middle
the range of services that we off offer
whether it's a critical incident stress
management
debriefings there's really a lot to say
right I I could really kind of do a deep
dive on any of these areas because I'm
passionate about the program and we do
amazing work so I want to open it up if
if that's okay and see if anybody yeah
and just just a very clearly State they
they really came through during the
tragedy that we had in New Hampshire
hospital uh providing support to our
staff whether it was from a behavioral
health standpoint because this is what
they do if you have a gaming addiction
or something use issue coing disorders
they can help you very much how to deal
with this and that's why the
confidentiality provision is out there
very much similar if you were going to a
doctor's office to talk to them to
protect that information and keep it
confidential so you can get those needed
Services because everybody at some point
in time does need to have something
addressed in in life um that happens to
them so I just want to make it really
clear when we're talking of services it
it's a whole gamut from everything you
can imagine that people need help with
including those of us who work for the
Department
and I'm and respectfully all the
wonderful people that I get to work with
at the legislature as well could Avail
themselves of these
services and and with that I I I I would
just say when we think about a range
right it could be anything from I'm
having difficulty with a conversation
with a with a colleague and you know
they're they're not receptive to to
anything around needing Direct Services
and I've had the the honor the you know
I never have the right words but
multiple times in my career to talk with
somebody who said I've been diagnosed
with a terminal illness I'm want to make
sure my family members are able to
access the resources that are available
to them through my position so we cover
the the full range coming for in
questions thank you sir thank you very
much for your testimony um they have
agreed to take questions um rip conable
question number one uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um it was sort of stated by the
sponsor that there's a great area in
terms of whether we're employeers or not
but I I don't see it that way we we are
not state employees so what is the
mechanism here that that we're going to
allow non-state employees participate in
program it's a very good question um and
the um at least no one has identified
any legal barriers as to the fact that a
um member of the legislature couldn't
Avail himself Services I think the key
here is the resources needed by our
agency to be able to provide them to
this with the same question I and I
think it is a very fair question
represent conable that um let's say that
the judicial branch decided that they
would like to also Avail it would be a
very similar process and I'm not aware
of any legal barriers and certainly you
can check in with your legal counsel for
the house just to double up on that to
making sure that there isn't something
that we're not aware of but I'm I'm not
aware of any barriers for providing
these services in fact uh we were
approached at the political subdivision
level I would agree that that we're
talking still executive branch in nature
but talking about either the county or
Municipal level so for example State
Police State Police can Avail themselves
and do Avail themselves of the employee
assistance program and it became so well
known that it was so helpful
particularly for those who are structal
jobs such as our law enforcement
officers that local law enforcement
agencies also wanted to Avail themselves
so we had Outreach from uh local law
enforcement to provide those Services as
well so it it has been discussed before
sers thank you Mr chair uh I heard you
say um something about three hours uh
what happens if the time goes over three
hours who ends up paying or what goes on
there yes I can I I appreciate the
question you know that the way that we
handle that my philosophy on that and
and one that was inherited I'm I'm in
the director role here uh since October
of 22 our previous director had been in
since 19 I believe 85 really so the
culture is established and to that point
um you know we our role is not to uh
report back to supervisors or HR really
that's kind of negotiated by the
employee if that's something that they
have to address in their in their kind
of employment role the same thing is you
know that that really is something that
we look at internally to be sure that um
those can be difficult conversations
sometimes depending on kind of how the
Rapport is developed and and a and a
sense of safety and things like that and
so that's all considered and to me it
would never be just because somebody hit
three sessions that we are now kind of
done right it's always a conversation
around how can this be helpful is this
supportive those are conversations we're
considering in the EAP role is there
another resource externally that might
be more appropriate but we are always
going to air to the side of being
supportive being present and and and and
negotiating those situations on an
individual level and this is one of
those rare ations that actually the
knowledgeable subject matter expert said
it in more words than the attorney would
uh I I think the answer that I heard to
the question was that if you exceed the
three hours that we would not be seeking
further money from that individual and
that's a clear I think a clear answer to
your question I'm sorry I can't answer
that you can't that's great no no
there's no there's never a cost to
individuals accessing Services there's
um thank
you other
questions I have a couple
um so my first question is um I'm
assuming this this is um adding in 14a
Colon 7 14a colon 6 talks about our the
group participation and group concerns
participation for members of the general
court um and the very first line says at
their own expense in this case um we are
we are making it the expense of the
people of New Hampshire um that are
going to pay for um our insurance
coverage in this Pro product um why
would it not be make more sense for
individual members to to participate in
to to ask that question because um we
it's not our mod it's not that that
would be my only thought there okay yeah
yeah so one of us will one you take yeah
I'm not sure if this fully addresses
that question um other than this is the
model that we uh kind of offer to other
agencies and so this cost allocation
formula is is something that all other
agencies agree to for
services um thank you I um I appreciate
the answer
um with respect we are not other
agencies um we are we're a little bit
different I think as rep c pointed out
we're we're not hired um we're elected
um which is a little different than your
State Police example um we also have a
section in this
uh a section of uh Group Insurance that
mentions and I'll quote it uh
participation in the state employees
Group insurance plan by a member of the
general court shall not be considered by
any judicial administrative executive of
our other body has evidence that a
member of the general court is an
employee of the
state um that language is missing from
this and I'm wondering why that is and
and representa Hill thank you very much
for for that question uh although we are
here in support of this bill and
certainly if it's funded we would be
open to the configuration that's
reported in this bill uh I do think that
that's a great question to take back to
either the attorneys at the a
legislative service who drafted this up
at the request of uh we did not draft
this legislation or placement uh and I
don't want to fault the people either
but we're just not in a position I think
answering the question because I think
you do raise a great question in terms
of words laid out in the same RSA
chapter 14a how does it play in with
other uh related sections that Define uh
or rather um Pro preclude a legislator
as being um um trying to come with the
right word uh as an employee and so
there's an inconsistency within that
chapter it really does need to be
reconciled in in this bill as well and I
suggest given that your timelines for
having and I know they are coming up
soon on the 15th for bills going to a
second committee but that's a great
question that should be resolved and
we're just I don't think we're in the
best position to answering the question
for you but you raise a really good
point sir fair enough um I'll go to a
different
question
um we've talked
it we've talked about the fact that
there are
um or you mentioned the fact that uh
this is a three basically a three-hour
service um right is that there's three
sessions that are available um I'm
assuming that um those three hours have
to be done would have to be done within
the time frame of our two-year
service so generally the way that has
been um
offered is you know three hours within
the fiscal year you know beginning
whenever the person initially accesses
us uh but I can tell you that because of
the role that we're in and the the
nature of the work there are some times
we meeting with somebody three times
doesn't uh fully offer the service that
they might feel they need or might
benefit from and so you know this it
doesn't it doesn't shut off at the end
of the fiscal year it's not it's not
monitoring that way we certainly look at
that we kind of take that into
consideration when we're working with
somebody but that it would never be um
the end of services because somebody met
that 3-hour
number can I ask sure to this line um
Richard thank you sure um just in the
same instance are there times when you
also have individuals that you've been
able to help in less than three discuss
and so it is it's not three is not
always the number yes and maybe one
conversation that is Bridges and
provides the assistance absolutely
speaking from personal experience of a I
really appreciate you you bringing that
in that way yeah so you know it's
voluntary right and so we want to just
be uh present and supportive and we're
kind of assessing somebody may call and
they have an initial description of
areas that they're they're struggling
with or they want to look for a resource
in you know part of what we're doing is
trying to understand the complexity of
the situation but at the same time
sometimes people just need a place to
have a conversation with somebody
outside of their family or somebody
outside of their work group right and so
that could be a 15minute conversation we
would never shut that down but if they
felt like they got what they needed
there then that that's it followup uh
quick followup uh is a lot of that too
is also a reference to
resources in terms of EAP my
understanding is that is such a
large component of the work this is not
individual therapy this is such a
reference
resource absolutely um program you know
sometimes dependent on the nature of
what the request is we may be Bridging
the Gap towards that service uh but you
know it really does kind of cover the
full ground in terms of what resources
we may be providing I mean we have uh
continued to bring in new programming
you know
around um preventative kind of
approaches employee Wellness mental
health and wellness so that we are not
kind of seen only as a crisis kind of uh
agency access or a crisis when
somebody's kind of at the point where
they've accessed all their resources or
aren't sure where to go but certainly
you know while we're not uh telling
people what to do we see our role is
trying to help figure people figure out
what their menu of options are around
whatever their concern might be and and
chairman Hill I just just to get back to
you on your ear ear question about
reconciliation with the other sections
in there one of the things you may want
to consider because it does strike one
that the program itself is called
employee System Program I'm not here to
suggest we change that name because it's
been in existence a long time but I do
think that if you are going to consider
the valuable Services forget about the
the cover of what the program's name is
but the types of referrals that you
could get to support the legislature for
all the life issues that they may have
to happen to them I think at a minimum
you may want to consider putting in a
sense that says nothing in this section
uh the new section A7 shall be construed
that a legislator is an employee I mean
something to that to making it crystal
clear because you raised a really good
point I think in terms of the confusion
that's caused by the name of the program
your functions clearly are as
legislators and not as employees and
having that distinction made within that
section would be particularly helpful
thank you last question I think for you
um I noticed in the in the brochure that
I read or it may have been online that
and you've mentioned it a couple of
times that the service be goes beyond
the state employee but to the family
member and then and I think in some
cases it may even go beyond that this
program was not designed that way or
written that way this was designed
strictly for the the legislator is that
am I accurate in that and why why would
that this this only talks to the to the
legislator not the not the extended
family or or anyone else is that by
Design so um I'm I'm not aware of the um
is the information brochure that you're
referring to but I'm taking you totally
at face value that it's some confusion
there as well my understanding uh from
just even just listening but also
working with Mr Lawless over the the
past few months over this legislation um
is that the same U the same mechanics in
terms of who those Services would be
provided to whether other family members
would apply also to the legislature so
I'm going to turn it back to him but I
think I came close maybe to clarifying
that it wouldn't just be limited to the
individual legislator but would be uh
extended just as it would with state
employees to the the family members as
well but now I'm answering and I
shouldn't because he knows the answer
and I'm just guessing at it I think you
did great yes so uh I believe the
language says members of your household
but again you know I would just put it
out there that um we're not kind of
grilling people about that if they call
in you know who's your family is who's
your family and if somebody reaches out
in that context then the resource would
be available so absolutely in my mind it
was it was always intended this language
this uh attempt to partner and offer a
resource would apply in the same way
members of your household family members
could access resources the same way
anybody else would be able to who
already accesses
us and and I think goes back and not
that we want to have so much legislative
wordsmithing here today but I do think
if you want to make it clear in your
legislation that it applies to family
members of The General coord as well
because it wouldn't just be
Representatives obviously uh the body
across the street as well and sometimes
they have cohabitate with you here the
Senate um you may want to to have that
clarification in the legislation as well
uh thank you I I think it goes if I'm
hearing you correctly it goes beyond
even um family members it's those that
live in your
household again you know I think that
our role is members of your household is
you know that that is your family is who
your family is and so if you you look at
members of your household as family or
that's how it's kind of pursued then we
would not say there'd be no barrier to
accessing our services how many people
do you have that can well that was the
first question as I read this how can
you
possibly um I think someone had
mentioned to us that there was not going
to be additional sta I think it's in the
in the fiscal note not additional staff
needed but yet you're able to absorb not
just 400
25 additional potential people but but
now the household members and and uh
family members it it it could be in the
thousands so how many people are you
actually um able to provide yeah
services for that's a great question you
know we we have seven staff members all
together right and we also seven busy
staff we're all busy for sure uh we are
also in the process of procuring a data
manager agement system which you know
that will help us kind of see the trends
that are emerging and and to streamline
our process part of our response to that
question is that we have Partnerships in
the community places that we can refer
resources already developed that are
easy to kind of share in those moments
and we and we exceed National averages
around you know it's never 100% access
from a particular Department right and
so you know while we exceed national uh
percentages around Service delivery um
our data management system is going to
give us a better handle on truly how
many people have access to US percentage
wise in these different areas and you
know as far as I'm concerned with the
program um creating a merging program
and meeting the needs that are there we
have the capacity you know and if if
that's something that as we think about
our service delivery model as we move
forward from all departments and if it
gets to a point where that's not true
then we'll explore that when we get
there but for now we have the ability to
do that and and rep Hill even though New
Hampshire is honored with having at
least to my knowledge in within the
United States the largest legislature
per population um that if you think
about it in perspective and I agree with
you that proportionately we can't get
the exact number because we do know 424
is the fixed number for you folks but
it's not necessarily a fixed number we
can certainly um you know project what
those may be for household members but
when you put that in comparison with I
think and I'm going to look to Michael
because I know it's at least around
10,000 state employees it is a smaller
percentage of the service population
that they already serving but it it's a
very thoughtful question on your part um
in terms of what impact that would have
but I think proportionally we're already
serving a very significant population
currently so hopefully that's a helpful
perspective thank you representative M
Carter thank you Mr chair uh thanks for
taking my
question what is the difference between
the employee assistance program that
would it obviously has a fiscal note
attached to us in the free 211 service
that uh is available that I've already
used and it was very helpful oh that's
great that's a great question I'm glad
to hear can we please make sure this
YouTube Channel video we can place that
because that's really great um feedback
around the two11 services that we have
uh in terms of getting people getting
access to Services here through it's
called service link is the other name
for the 211 so thank you for that
commentary the YouTube channel is taken
care of we got that yeah so so what I
would say there is that there are a
number of resources available to to
folks already and so sometimes we may be
simply connecting them with resources
like that uh depending on what the ask
is but generally even if there's a
service that might be offered through
say 211 you know for instance Financial
concerns right you could call 211 and uh
they would probably point you toward
your town and maybe even some financial
resources available there we've we've
worked with referred uh people to um
Green Path debt management programs debt
consolidation programs uh the Federal
Credit Unions often have a great
resources internally and so what I would
say is we have a knowledge base around
resources in particular areas that may
go deeper than other resources and they
can be complimentary to those resources
the other piece that I would say is even
those Standalone resources that are are
kind of being mentioned uh they may not
have as a robust kind of um menu of
resources that we would be helping folks
connect
with so I lied my last question is going
to be channeling our former colleague uh
representative Neil
Kirk where is the language in this
section that deals with the security of
the information of the U of the
participant those that go to um seek
your
services and being that I saw the
honorable one just yesterday testifying
in bills we are always very
conscientious of protecting individual
um personal information but alter turn
it over to Mr laws how we currently not
only maintain confidentiality from a
statutory perspective meaning the
information he has is protected under
what he he used attorney client I would
also say pretty much similar to
standards that we would see in terms of
clinicians doctors in Hippa in terms of
those kind of protections but in terms
of security protection of information
within our agency we certainly have a
very robust Safeguard in terms of that
information saved but I'm going to turn
it over to this gentleman because he
deals with it on a daily basis yes so
the the safeguards are you know of the
utmost importance and so that's part of
that discussion around information that
uh we are privy to never leaves our
building you know as it's kind of
currently constituted now these are EAP
staff that are held to these standards
uh including myself around Hippa and 42
CFR and when it comes to even uh
capturing information about who who
we're working within that moment it uh
to make sure that we're providing the
best resource available to that person
uh there you know the The Limited
information that's taken down that never
gets into any kind of file like a
personnel file we have our own process
internally and at the minimum it it
would be uh non-identifiable information
in in a space like that to speak to the
fact that uh the person was made aware
of the limits of
confidentiality and from there it's very
limited to maybe met with client or you
know provided a resource so there's no
deep language around the actual uh
individual who's accessing our services
and at this Point currently it stays in
our location behind minimum of two
locked doors as required by Hippa and
42cfr
okay anything else from anyone seeing
none thank you for your help thank you
thank
you I have no other pink cards um
although I see pink cards are coming
different
bill so I will close the hearing on
House Bill
1363 just a couple minutes and we'll
start up
with House Bill
1,000 I think is next on our sheet
right
yeah
I'll open the hearing on House Bill 1000
recognize the prime sponsor honorable
Marjorie Smith welcome to legislative
Administration thank you very much I'm
delighted to be here and I love to be in
the small room it reminds me of the old
days um uh Mr chair and committee
members I am really quite honored to
introduce House Bill 1000 relative to
classifying the Hampshire legislator
Services as public service for certain
federal purposes the very first thing I
want to say in honor of my long
relationship with um Neil Kirk and my
service on the uh finance committee is
that there is no State money involved
there's no fiscal note it has nothing to
do with State money and that should
cause you at least some breath of
release this is a public service loan
forgiveness program it was created in
the Year 2007 under the GE W Bush
Administration as an incentive to get
young people to enter into public
service and here it is 17 years later
and we see even more clearly how
important it is for us to get young
people involved in public service they
are going to be determining the future
of the state and of this country and we
need them um when I went to college
College my total uh bill for tuition
room and board for a year was
$1700 and that was in a private college
that wasn't in a public university um
adjusted for you know today's
uh rate that would be the equivalent of
$117,000 you find me somebody who is
faced with a tuition bill today
full-time that's a tuition room on board
that's
$177,000 getting educated is very
important if we're going to have a a
future small D democracy and it costs a
lot of money this program applies only
to federal student
loans and it's not to say well you've
taken out a loan and now you shouldn't
take the responsibility for paying off
the loan you you are not eligible until
you have made
120 payments that's 10 years of payments
and payments you know fulfilling your
your full obligation and it's only
then that um you would be eligible for
this program and it is not a question of
being a state or federal employee it's a
question of working in federal state
local government US Government any level
nonprofit but all in terms of Public
Service it's it's acknowledging public
service and it's providing some small
relatively small incentive um we all got
our W2 forms this week um and um you
know they say we get paid $200 of course
we don't we get $183 because they take
out for um Social Security Medicare
whatever it is Medicare um but if you
look at the form the
number that's on there your employment
identification number is the state and
it's the state that issues those forms
so that even here we recognize that
those of us who are working because of
our commitment we're not working for the
money we're acknowledged by the State
and by the federal government in terms
of that great
$200 um I'm not going to go on anymore
except to say that I don't I'm not going
to get compensation under this nor are
my children nor are my
grandchildren I am committed to this
program not for any personal benefit but
for a benefit for all of society in that
this is a way with without the state
having to come up with one
dime to make it possible for us to be
more welcoming to the young people who
have stepped up to the plate and
cooperated with the concept of public
service and the value of public service
so I hope you will find your way to say
yes and I think there'll be a number of
people behind me who will be happy to
answer any technical questions and you'd
rather hear from them than from
me thank you uh no matter how inaccurate
that is um are there any
questions seeing none um you're off the
hook and well you know I've been doing
this for a few years Mr chairman so I'm
kind of used to it you've been on but
I'm I'm really very pleased I have one
question for you oh good sure so um our
researcher did um some background
from this the program itself uhhuh
um and and it comes back to say
therefore to be eligible for the program
the borrower must be a qualified
employe working for a qualified employer
for the requisite time
period and they list a government
employer is quote any us-based
government organ or us-based government
organization at any level federal state
local or tribal this includes employers
such as US military Public elementary
and secondary schools public colleges
and universities Public Child and Family
Service agencies and special
governmental districts including
entities such as public transportation
Water Bridge District or housing
authorities but it doesn't
include any elected members member of
the of
this I'm I'm sorry I should be I
shouldn't be laughing I should be
serious the members of Congress um are
eligible for all kinds of benefits that
no one else in this country is eligible
for they fall into special categories in
terms of the health insurance and and
everything else
um they are not they are not one of the
huddled masses that we're talking about
now it also says that um uh partisan
political organizations are not
eligible and that is true I mean the
Republican National Committee you're
aring for the Republican National
Committee or let's say the Democratic
National Committee for example um or
working for them in the state you
wouldn't be eligible in this but that's
not who elected me or who elected you we
were elected by people and I don't know
about you Mr chair but I know I
represent all the citizens of Durham I
don't represent a political party this
is
not um our role here is not as employees
of a political of a partisan political
system and the more we remember that the
better off we'd all be thank you thank
you uh yet representative
shott I just was wondering if uh you're
a legislator and you decide to go to
college and you stay as a legislator for
10 years would you get it work the same
way I'm I'm afraid you have to have paid
you have to have borrowed the money to
be educated and
paid 120 times for 10 years to have paid
the um the loan and only then would you
be
considered for this program
so I quick does that does that help it
would be probably you you'd have to pay
for 10 years and you have to serve
years well so you be serving 20 years
representable can you help us a little
it it says former as well so to the way
I read it is that former legislators
would also be as long as they paid up
into it so you would be able to serve a
term and then you would qualify if then
you reached but right in the bill it
says former as well okay thank you thank
you but you have to have the 10 years of
public service representative sellers
now thank you Mr chair so you just uh
brought up a good point this not just
includes from today forward but would it
include all legislators that have ever
served he ain't going
forward if they
had if they I think I would like either
the
clerk or
um someone else who could professionally
answer that I will just say to you by
the way that the commissioner of
administration
uh commissioner Arling has has uh has
told me and told me that I could say
that he has absolutely no problem with
this there is no
State
financial input of this no State
financial input all it is is following
the federal law and the federal
guidelines all that has to happen is
someone has to
verify your 10 years of public service
and it might be that for you it's two
years of working in the legislature and
six years of um working in a not from
not for-profit organization that is
considered public service and how many
did I get up to eight and two years in
something else so it wouldn't have to be
10 years here in in the legislature all
this does is say that for the time that
you have been in the
legislature um that service would count
as public as public service under the
federal law and I can't imagine anything
that's more public service because we're
not doing it for the
you second pink card we have uh is
representative of Ellen Reed who ask for
five minutes and supports the
bill and I'm a co-sponsor thank you Mr
chair and thank you honorable members uh
the question that was just asked I'm
going to clarify because the reason I am
here testifying is because I am very
familiar with this process because I
have worked in nonprofits and in
government um organizations which I'll
testify to on another bill later um in
order to qualify for this program you
have to have made 120 on time payments
while in public service post 2007 so
people who served before 2007 wouldn't
qualify if you served but weren't making
payments or hadn't yet borrowed the
money you wouldn't qualify you have to
be making payments while you're in
public
service great okay so to continue on yes
you can mix and match any of those
nonprofit Public Service uh things there
are many rules regarding which
organizations count as public service
yes um you can't work for a political
organization we are not political when
we are here we are serving the public we
are public servants that is the
definition of our role here we may
personally adhere to to partisan
politics we may campaign on that and
that's Exempted of course if you're
working for a campaign but when we're
here in our professional capacity we are
not
partisans however Congress Congress
passed the law Congress Exempted
themselves as they should recuse
themselves since this would have
actually applied to them much in the
same way that it is against the
Constitution for them to pay themselves
but they have to pay if they do a pay
increase they have to do it for the
future uh legislature they would have
qualified under this have they not
specifically Exempted themselves they
explicitly did not exempt state
legislators think about that they went
through some federal contractors some
State contractors apply or qualify some
don't and they get into the details
about well if the state doesn't have any
other resources and they had to go
through a private contractor then those
private contractors are considered
public service but if they had other
resources so they got really in the
nitty-gritty ex uh recused themselves
from it but specifically did not exempt
state legislators perhaps because some
of them worked in their own State
legislates and knew how little they got
paid and how much they would have
appreciated help with their public
service
um the form that is received by the
federal government from the employer in
this case the state it's very short it's
only six lines it basically says the
name and address of the the organization
in this case it would be the state that
the start and end dates of the public
service and the employer identification
number the employer identification
number on the W2 that we just all got so
by the way I understand that we and I
really appreciate the philosophical
argument that we aren't employees of the
state on a state level because what
you're saying is a sentiment I fully
agree with that we aren't here on a
transactional basis we aren't here to do
work because we're getting paid to do it
and I fully agree with that we're here
for a much more sacred Duty however for
the federal government there is no
situation where the federal government
issues a W2 or I rather should say
requires a W2 to be issued unless you're
an employee so federal government
purposes regardless of our philosophical
agreement federal government considers
us employees we get a W2 we get federal
taxes I should say the Social Security
and Medicare taken out the reason we
don't get Federal Income T tax taken out
is because it's set at $200 which Falls
below the tax brackets we make too
little to pay federal income tax the Ein
employer identification number
02600 618 is the same Ein that is issued
to every state employee whether you're
with the doe or the do or you're a staff
person here you all have all of us all
10 to 156 I can't remember who what they
said in the last bill state employees
have this exact same Ein employer
identification number $200 is in the
federal or sorry the state constitution
because that's our salary it's our
salary in the Constitution the reason
we're no longer considered like an
employee is because now our salary has
fallen below what we consider minimum
wage but that doesn't change the fact
that that was always our salary in the
Constitution and at that time yes when
you uh adjust for CPI it's still you
know below livable wage but at the time
housing was so widely available that it
was enough to buy a four acres with an
improve improved house an improved
structure it was enough to buy a farm in
other words it was a livable wage it was
enough to live off of so we were always
intended to be fairly compensated but I
I am getting getting farfield because
this is not about us being a state
employee and I'm going to get to that in
fact the language that um DHS suggested
on the last bill saying that all these
other things you know despite this this
is not evidence that we are employees
it's is also
here continuing on um so myself and
other people when we've applied for our
Public service loan forgiveness the
accounting office it's the accounting
office that has decided to not certify
us as full-time employees in public
service and the reason I asked
specifically for the reasons and I was
emailed the reason specifically was
because they did not consider that we
were hired through the normal hiring
process as the chair had mentioned and
also uh fired through the normal normal
firing process however there are other
employees true employees of the state
with that same EI in number who are also
elected we elect the Secretary of State
we elect the state treasurer
we elect the clerks of the chambers and
they get salary and they have the same
pslf and uh the prime sponsor already
mentioned that the commissioner of the
Department of administrative Services
has already said he has no reason to
oppose the certification of public
service for legislators for federal
pslf um and I already said that we do
say notwithstanding provision of uh RSA
14 A6 so in other words we're not
employees we're saying we're not
employees for the purposes of the state
the federal government already thinks
we're employees but we're not employees
for the purpos of the state we're just
accessing benefits just like we have
with health insurance we had that law
that gave us access to health insurance
employees that may have cost us a little
bit of money by the way potentially a
little bit but this costs us nothing and
not only does it not cost New Hampshire
any money whatsoever but since New
Hampshire is a federal income tax donor
state it means that we'll be getting
some of those dollars that are now going
to other states back meanwhile the vast
majority of States already consider
their legislators to be employees so
they don't need this type of legislation
they're automatically those other state
legislators automatically qualify for
pslf and get pslf in other states just
from the friends I have serving in
office in States I know for a fact and
have confirmed Texas state employees
their legislators are state employees
Tennessee Maine Montana Most states
consider their state their legislators
state employees so they don't need this
legislation and here's the thing since
we're a donor state that means our tax
dollars are going to forgive
Massachusetts state legislators in
California state legislators why aren't
our tax dollars forgiving our state
legislators when we desperately need
young people in this chamber why why are
we why are we donating to California
state
legislators the pslf program was
designed to incentivize young people to
get into public service and that's
exactly what we need in this state so
just simply passing a measure to say yes
being a legislator is public service we
all know it's public service and help
more young people to run for office um
will help us
now I do want to say that um
I think I actually covered all my points
Public Service yes we're not so we can
just to be very
clear we can declare that yes we are
full-time public servants the federal
government and still say we're not
employees on the state level that is
possible that's what this bill does and
I'm happy to take
questions thank you um representative
cost thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I don't know
any one that considers what we do
full-time um can you can you speak to a
the full-time versus what I believe we
are which is a part-time volunteer thank
you so much for the question I actually
have a ton of notes on that issue and I
didn't want to like expand my testimony
by delving into that but I'm now I get
to okay so we are salaried right we're
not hourly we get $200 for the entire
term your salary and your salary for a
piece of work again not hourly a piece
of work what is that piece of work the
piece of work is you are the
representative for your constituents 247
365 days a year now if you say is our
session work part-time it's absolutely
part-time if you say our is our
committee work part-time kind of depends
what time of the year it is so maybe
half the year it could potentially be
full-time if you're like me and put 16
bills in and are on 59 bills it's pretty
pretty darn it's actually overtime um um
but in terms of committee work it can be
part-time um but in terms of being
responsive to your constituents in terms
of emails zooms texts that I know I have
done way over time and it's all every
season every holiday 247 I've taken 11:
PM calls from constituents whose
electricity was turned off unjustly and
I had to go and text the eversource
lobbyist and get their electricity
turned on in the middle of the night
247365 now maybe maybe you're not like
me maybe you don't put in 16 bills maybe
maybe you don't answer calls at 11 p.m
and it's up to your boss it's up to your
boss the legis the uh the electorate
your constituents whether or not they
think you have fulfilled that peace meal
work that they gave you a salary for did
you do the job for the last two years
that we hired you to do and if they're
happy with your work then they'll keep
you employed and if they're not not
happy with your work then they'll
replace you as they should if you're not
actually doing your end of the work but
it's salary it's for the fact that we
cannot take off if you get pulled over
like with a DUI or something you're
still a state W and that goes in the
news you can't take off our
responsibility at any point during those
two years that is what we're getting
for any other further
much uh last pin card I have is for our
honorable clerk Paul
Smith who has two minutes he says I'll
try not to take it Mr
chairman good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
Paul Smith Clerk of the house and I am
neither in favor nor opposed to this
legislation just wanted to provide you
with a couple of uh Salient points um
I've been asked several times over the
last few years uh by current and former
members uh about the process uh of
certifying their service as public
service for the purposes of PC pslf um
and in those cases I've uh referred them
down to the general court administrative
office because they are the folks that
handle it for the record uh 20 years
after I graduated college last year uh I
was the recipient of that PS LF program
uh myself where my last $4,500 in loans
was forgiven but not after um extensive
paperwork uh and and hassles from the
federal government which I'm sure
surprises you um that being said uh at
the request of the sponsors I did reach
out to several of my colleagues uh last
evening uh to ask specifically about
their states because again this is a
state decision this is this is a choice
of this legislature to make in in terms
of whether or not you want to recognize
that service for these Federal purposes
um I did hear from uh 13 states um and
uh of that 10 were yes and three were no
and I'm talking about not in terms of
employment I don't want to get into that
debate that doesn't involve me that
being said for the purposes of the
program itself eligibility 10 were in in
support and those included Maine Hawaii
Vermont Virginia Florida Kansas Al
Alabama Washington Minnesota and
Pennsylvania and the three that were not
eligible for the program despite their
recognition of of employees is New
Mexico Kentucky and
Texas um the form itself having filled
it out that that we would be filling out
if it were our responsibility would
would is a small part of the box that
literally just says the dates of service
um and that is something that could be
managed uh very easily my only uh
consideration in terms of looking at the
bill is on line n where it has the
commissioner being the person
responsible for filling out the
paperwork uh this is the legislative
branch and I would defer to the
legislative branch officials namely
myself or the general court
Administrative Office to be the the
persons who are the the record keepers
of the branch uh to to file um those
paperwork that paperwork if if uh if it
is going to be filled out so I just
wanted to um again mention that this is
uh this is something that has been
brought to me several times over the
last few years um and you know
clarification um is is certainly
appreciated one way or the other um and
I have I'm able to answer any questions
you might have thank you Mr clerk uh
representative sers thank you m uh Mr
chair and maybe you can answer this or
not uh is this constitution
I don't see that it's not constitutional
um it it literally designates for the
purposes of a federal program your
service as being public service so I I
don't see that this has any
constitutional this is my opinion uh I
don't see that it has any constitutional
issues so I'll follow up on that um
would it require any disclosures
um under the current form of our
disclosure that's a very good question I
would think that
um firstly anybody who participates in
the pslf program when if their loan is
Forgiven they have to report that on
their income tax filings uh so uh I'm
waiting for my paperwork from last year
from the federal government so hopefully
they stick to the January 31st deadline
uh of mailing me my form so that I can
uh file that uh with the appropriate
paperwork
um in terms
of what your your requirements for
filing at the beginning of a banum are
are your income derived from your
profession uh so I'm not I'm not
entirely sure that this would be in that
same
vein thank you um further
questions
c u thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question this goes back to the
the fulltime parttime thing everyone
that I know knows this the politicians
here like us side obviously a full-time
that's obviously a full-time position
but um the legislators here most of them
have other jobs and this is a part-time
role so how do we Square the full-time
Service as a job like I think of things
like a maricor or something like that or
a teacher there obviously full-time
whereas every everything here is known
to be
part-time uh just just want your opinion
on the difference between the full and
all I'll I'll mention about that is is
in that list of uh list of states that I
mentioned before um only Pennsylvania is
considered full-time and they are
actually full-time all yearlong
legislature um so they're going from
January through December every single
year uh Massachusetts is a full-time
legislature I didn't hear from them so I
didn't include them on my list but of
the ones I mentioned um only only
Pennsylvania is a full-time legislature
so it is it is truly your
determination that's why this is this is
determination
um talk to us a little about the the
request by a former member of the
general court um how how would that be
handled um if would it just purely be
able to say this person served in the
legislature from from this year to this
year and just assume that they had a
full-time 30 hours um again I that that
determination about full-time is is one
that you all would be making in policy
uh if if this were law if if if you left
the legislature at the end of this term
and called me in March of next year and
said Paul I'd like to uh do this Public
service loan forgiveness program and I
have the form uh would you be able to
sign it um you would hand me the form
and I would fill out the small box at
the top that's says your start date and
your end date uh in terms of your
service which would be the the um first
day I was a legislator and the last day
I was a legisl that's correct sir thank
you
um thank you thank you Mr chair just in
followup to that that would be if there
was an addendum to change line nine um
well if if that was changed to the clerk
I mean but again it doesn't have to be
the clerk it can be the administrative
office that's your preference uh it it
doesn't really matter to be to be honest
um I I would note of the states that I
mentioned before Hawaii Vermont Virginia
Pennsylvania all their clerks are the
persons that's certifi okay thank you
clarification any further questions
being none and I have no other pink
cards thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee always a pleasure to be in
front of my favorite committee I knew
that was coming up um thanks very much
uh with that I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill
1000 and just a second we'll be opening
okay I'm going to open the hearing on
House Bill 1290 recognize the prime
sponsor um rep lyd yes um who said she
promises to send in written testimony I
do I promise all right thanks very much
welcome to legislative Administration
thank you very much chairman uh for the
opportunity to speak today I'm
representative Crystal Lloyd from nashaa
board six Hillsboro 8 um I want to begin
by saying that I Lov my days up here in
conquer I was one of those kids who was
always who always loved to learn and
doing this work has given me a true
passion I'm truly grateful with to serve
with all of you I've made friends and
connections across the aisle I and have
claimed even some of my local
connections as my new family more
importantly I'm honored to walk into
rep's Hall on behalf of my
constituents as a kid touring government
buildings I wondered what it would be
like to sit in those chairs and now I
know I'm humbled and
grateful when I first told my mom I was
running for office she apologized to me
she said oh Chris I'm sorry we weren't
born into a rich family I wish we were
Rich enough to support you to allow you
to do what you
love she knew that I live alone she knew
that my mortgage my utilities everything
was 100% on my working
shoulders I would need to balance both
I assured her that I would figure it out
if I won and just because of her
reaction I worked extremely hard on my
campaign this was something that I
wanted to prove could be done and
possibly I could help change
it I started thinking about what she had
said and I thought about all of those
doors that I knocked on so many were
happy to see me a young self-made
working woman running for office and I
won my boss at the time said that she
would allow me to use my time off
however I noticed in December of 2022
that there would be an
issue I went from receiving a bonus in
November 2022 for a job well done on a
very large project to my boss suddenly
being very suspicious of my working
hours suddenly I was having check-in
sessions to see what I worked on all day
um I was accused of paying more
attention to State House duties than my
day-to-day I was working 15-hour days in
a salaried position and as you know
legislative duties didn't really start
until January
20123 um I became the department
scapegoat because I was assumed it it
was assumed that I was just working on
New Hampshire issues which of course had
not started
yet um I knew i' knew I knew that I'd
need to find a new job but this was now
going to be difficult given the
legislative calendar I would need to
immediately ask for days off as a new
hire for the ve at the very least the
house session days my job search was
further delayed because I found out I
needed another knee surgery and I needed
to keep my job until the surgery date
for the medical insurance and the
short-term disability from January to
March 2023 the earliest I was able to
schedule my surgery my attendance here
was
sporadic I remember one day you all were
voting on education bills while I was
crying in my workplace back bathroom
because I was not allowed the day off to
vote on my constituent
behalf the reason I couldn't take the
day off for voting session despite
having a crude time off uh was because
of my co-workers birthday it was the
same day that I needed off my
constituents were not represented for
Life altering votes due to a long-term
lack of Staffing in my department and my
co-worker
birthday I checked with some lawyer
friends and found out that I didn't have
any recourse I didn't have any
protections I take my oath of office
very seriously and every single absence
broke my heart I was counting down the
days to my knee surgery in late March
and just over one week after my PCL
surgery I was on the house floor in a
wheelchair for the state budget
vote during my leave for my surgery I
worked with a recruiter to find a new
job we had carefully had to plan when to
bring up my State Rep work with any new
employer I made it a condition of my new
employment that they allow me the T the
time off to go to session days and
committee work and I haven't missed a
day
since however at the end of December my
position was eliminated in a group
layoff I am yet again needing to find a
full-time new position of employment
while balancing State Rep employee State
Rep
schedules whenever whatever my employer
or whatever employer decides to take me
on they'll need to immediately Allow Me
session days off this is a hard ask and
right now I'm trying to stretch whatever
savings I have in order to get through
as much legislative session as possible
I will remind you that I live alone my
mortgage is 100% on my own shoulders my
fiance is not moving in until
September having this kind of protection
would make it easier for me to get the
time off approved I am not the only rep
that this would
help this bill is very limited in scope
with the house so evenly divided even
one absence on session days on both
sides makes a difference I believe all
parties are aware of just how crucial it
is that every rep is in their seat to
vote these are lifechanging issues for
the people we represent
and that is something I don't ever take
lightly I have limited HB 1290 to
session days only because those are
mandatory committee days meetings
campaign events these are not protected
in this
bill I have capped a maximum number of
hours that an employee is allowed to
request I have also included a hardship
clause in case a business needed to be
Exempted for any
reason there is one piece that that I
would like to put through an amendment
on and that's line number five it should
say up to 168 hours this is the maximum
hours cap however I wanted to see the
committee's response to this bill before
drafting any amendment to include any
potential additional changes uh that the
committee thought might be
helpful why is it important to fix this
issue why do we need
protection here is what I believe New
Hampshire has gained due to my
participation in the legisl
body I have over 16 years of nonprofit
experience 14 of those have been in
payroll and finance I've served on the
board for several community-based
organizations due to places I've worked
I have knowledge and experience in
Animal Welfare welfare Health Care
Finance Union contracts labor laws
recruitment volunteer management
education organ and tissue donation
event planning and permitting and more
I've worked in organization ations that
ranged from three employees to
8,000 additionally my family has
veterans dating back to the
Revolutionary War and I personally have
had to deal with severe injury and
resulting long-term Rehabilitation
processes that is just me alone all of
these unique experiences which my
personal voice brings to this body when
I've been not working my 9-to-5 job have
been or I have been able to substitute
on other committees to contribute
additional knowledge I'm only one person
you all have your own voices and your
own experiences that you're bringing in
the legislative body every time you
attend there are many other working reps
that have rsums and experiences that
are similar to mine and some that are
very different from mine their
experiences should be represented as
well they should have a voice at the
table additionally I believe not having
these protection protections lead leaves
our volunteer legislature vulnerable to
influence to be clear this was not my
situation at at this level but I was
drafting this bill and it made me
question what would happen if an emplo
employer or a manager of a state
representative understood what bills
were being voted on and denied the
legislature the requested day
off without this kind of protection we
are left at the mercy of our employer to
allow us the time as both parties are
aware just one absence can drastically
change a vote in this nearly evenly
divided House people of working age ages
19 to 64 make up the driving force of
our state's economy these are people we
need to hear more representation from I
appreciate our volunteer legislature I
appreciate that I'm able to serve
without needing to be a career
politician or a lawyer
I love that we have such a variety of
experience in our legislative body
however it's a double-edged sword
because we don't receive much in
compensation our legislative body leans
heavily on people who are retired who
are business owners who are managers
rather than front-facing employees and
independently wealthy individuals or
individuals who are able to rely on
their spouse's
income we are leaving out so many voices
which need to be directly
represented this bill hb1 1290 in my
opinion is the least we can do for our
working Representatives like myself and
immediately necessary to protect our
jobs and most importantly our
constituents voices in the
legislature so thank you I'm open to
questions thank you for your testimony
um other
questions I have a quick one yeah go um
you show here in Roman three an employer
may not discharge an employee who is a
member of the general
court
um should an employer be allowed to
reassign or hire someone else for your
position I would think that that would
be acceptable um I think that ultimately
I mean needs must in an organization
that I don't want to impact businesses
negativ ly however um I really think
that we need to be able to be allowed to
be on the floor for house
votes thank you for your answer um is
would you
also what would be your opinion of
um this uh a size limit on um who this
would apply to whether it would be I
don't know uh 50 employers that have
over 50 employees or is there was that
considered and it was considered be yeah
I I thought about that originally um and
I I left it out right now and I wanted
to see what the committee's thoughts on
this were um because I did include the
hardship clause which allows any
employer the ability to apply for um
hardship situations and what would those
hardships so potentially be again I've
worked for I've worked for nonprofits
that had only three employ es um I can
understand only having three employees
would leave you a a major shortage um in
staff um and Staffing requirements um
would be my main concern so I completely
understand that from an employer
perspective last question for me is
um I would assume um or maybe I
shouldn't assume um was there any
opportunity for you to have the
discussion with your employer prior to
running yes and I did and she said that
she would um support me being at the
state house um however it's never a
problem until it
you yeah no other hands went up so I'm
saying no other questions um thank you
very much for your testimony um I do
have a pink card uh from representative
Ellen Reed um who asked for five minutes
it would be great if you could be less
so we could get back I think I can
accommodate the chair's request for the
record my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 new Mark and newfields and
I just want to preface my testimony by
saying I was told that I came in a
little bit hot during the last uh Bill
hearing and I want to apologize any of
you that know me personally no I'm a
little fiery um I want to testify to my
personal experience with this issue I'm
very grateful that the prime sponsor has
put this bill in uh after getting
elected I got I decided I needed a
part-time job instead of my regular
full-time job so I went and looked and I
got a part-time job driving for public
transit a
government
position um and uh and they told I
explained I'm a State Rep and I'm going
to need a little bit of flexibility
around certain days and they said that's
fine and I got hired and I worked and
everything was fine we got a new manager
um and then things weren't fine and when
I asked and this is back before we were
very very very very closely divided this
is four terms ago and so bills dying on
a tie was not really a thing so much it
was like happened once a year maybe and
I asked for time off to go to session
and my employer said absolutely not you
have to work and uh I found out later
that my employer my my manager this
particular person was not politically
aligned with me um and I missed session
that day and a bill failed it went
against the way I would have voted on a
tie and I let my employer know that that
was never going to happen again and I
asked um several people at the state
house uh the speaker's office I asked my
leadership I asked different
administrative staff people if they
could give me a letter not a letter
telling my employer that they have to
excuse me but only a letter quoting the
Constitution because in our state
constitution several things the general
court can excuse a member from jury duty
jury duty by law um excuses you from
work so the weird thing was that if I
had gotten jury dut Duty I would have
been excused from work legally but even
though I have a constitutional Duty that
supersedes jury duty and I can get out
of jury duty to go do
session that doesn't excuse me legally
from work so we're giving more
protections of jury duty than our
constitutional requirement second thing
in the Constitution that even the police
cannot detain me from going to session
the police cannot detain me even if I'm
actively speeding running stop lights
they cannot they can follow me they can
wait for me outside a session they can
write me up afterwards but they cannot
detain me if I'm on my way to represent
my constituents and thirdly and this
rarely happens but the police can be
ordered to come and pick me up at my
home and bring me in by force meaning
forget employer and employee relations
and work and all of that it's saying my
constitutional Duty that I sacredly took
when I entered into public office
supersedes even my autonomy and freedom
that that's the agreement I made by
taking on office and all I wanted was
those quotes from the Constitution from
somebody in this building and I was
unable to get
it that employment didn't end well but
um anyway because of my experience and
because of the experience of other
people and how important it is to get
not just people who don't have to work
but the people who have to work to
represent the working people of New
Hampshire I would urge you to support
this and I'll take
questions are there any questions yes
representative turot I kind of just want
to make a statement that's why I had to
have a break in service would you
believe would you believe would you
believe that's why I had to have a break
in service because one road agent
wouldn't let me go the next the new one
did I would absolutely believe that and
what the prime sponsor spoke of is
something that that did not happen to
her but might happen absolutely happened
to me this person knew I mean it's it's
not a secret what my beliefs are
politically and uh he absolutely did not
want me to do my job and serve my
constituents in that
manner any further questions seeing none
thank you very much thank
you uh last pink card I have um is um
and I'm hopeful I pronounce it correctly
uh representative biman
thank
you three minutes uh support the bill
absolutely thank you Mr chair thank you
committee my name is Paige boschman I am
a registered nurse and the newest member
of the State uh House of Representatives
so thank you for having me here today uh
shouldn't take too long I am here to
support the bill as a mother of a young
family with a full-time job which I
would not be able to support my family
without this job my partner works as
well I am actually a registered nurse
with close to 15 years of experience
with women's in reproductive health and
a specialty in perinatal mental health I
think you know we talked about the skill
set um I actually worked last night so
I've had one hour of sleep since
yesterday morning and I've been here all
day testifying on bills because this is
important and because as a working
person I represent my Board of of
workingclass people and I'm very lucky
that I'm a nurse and I'm able to have
this position which enables me to be
here I have had many daytime jobs and if
I was in that position right now I would
need this bill to be able to continue to
do what I do and you know that can
happen right that might happen this year
who knows so I I hope that we can pass
this bill so that workingclass people
like myself like my family will be able
to to continue to be represented thank
you very much thank you um welcome to
legislative Administration and to the
house um would you be willing to take
questions if there are any of
course are there
questions seeing none you're off the
hook thank you I'm running on coffee and
adrenaline if that was your only
question ah thank
you um I have no other pink cards for
this bill um if there's no one else
I'm assuming he's not filling out the
card for this Bill thank you so I'll
close the the hearing
and I think we are ready to jump in
immediately with House Bill
FN this is for what
no no I don't think she did that's 19
You2 uh the chair would recognize uh the
prime sponsor for House Bill
1629 nope two two
more what happened to
oh um and I would like a moment here of
personal privilege to um to indicate
that this bill
um brings up a um a
topic um that is currently under
investigation and I would like to
caution everyone in the room that we
will not be talking about um specific
instances we are going to only talk
about the language of the bill um and
only the language of the bill and I will
stop um any any conversation that goes
beyond the language of the bill bill so
with that I would welcome representative
Weber um thank you welcome back to
legislative Administration thank you sir
um my for the record my name is Lucy
Weber I represent chesher County
District five which is Walpole and S uh
the I think 11th town I've represented
in chesher
County this without discussing the
situation out of which this bill arose
at all uh the issue here
is what the duties of the Attorney
General are when it comes to the
attorney general's attention that a
member of the general court may not
still be resident in the district from
which they were elected that's the
language of the bill and the that is
important because it is the job of the
Attorney General to investigate any
criminal matters that may arise out of
that but it is only the general court
that can deal with the qualifications of
its own
members so the way the bill is drafted
first of all it's not when the Attorney
General hears a vague rumor that
somebody may be living somewhere else
it's when the attorney general has
probable cause to believe that they are
not living somewhere else the Attorney
General must give notice not uh to the
speaker and to the minority leader and
to the clerk of the respective body or
the Senate President and minority leader
and Clerk and the purpose of that is so
that those legislative leaders can then
make a
determination of the qualifications of
the members of their body in accordance
with the rules of their body and the
wishes of the members of their body
because that's the
only place where that the house controls
the the membership and the Senate
controls its membership the Attorney
General doesn't get to weigh in on that
and so the way the bill is drafted I
also specifically said that the Attorney
General shall not be compelled to
provide details of any ongoing criminal
investigation beyond the issue of
residency that's all they
need to disclose beyond that what they
are doing is not our business and so
with that I'll conclude my testimony
it's really just a matter of clarifying
how the different branches of government
are going to communicate to each other
and making sure that
everybody uh that the relevant people in
each branch of government have the
information that they need to uh do
their own
jobs and with that I'd be glad to take
any questions that anybody has thank you
um representative nutting Wong hey um as
I read this um it just says that the um
the that the Attorney General will
contact or notify the presiding officer
minority leader and clerk um then
what that's not a matter for this
legislation the then what is a matter
either for the Senate and the Senate
rules or if there aren't any rules for
the leadership and the membership of the
Senate and for the house the leadership
and the membership of the house to
determine but I didn't think that that
was something I needed to include in the
legislation I think that is a matter for
each separate legislative body and as we
know uh the things that we enact in this
legislature don't bind the next
legislature they may have a very
different way of dealing with it and the
other thing is that over the
years the when this issue has arisen
generally each case is so very different
from the last that it is very different
to come up with a hard and fast
procedure I mean I can think of an issue
where um this this wasn't ever an issue
before this body but we did have a
member whose house burned
down and it took
well over a year for the house to be
rebuilt I've had friends in that
situation live in a trailer on their
property which is no problem but that
member was living in a rented apartment
I don't know whether that was in his
district or not but if it was not in his
district I don't think in that situation
that a member would lose their residency
simply because they were in the process
of rebuilding I mean we you know members
can stay at their Lakehouse in the
summer and they don't lose their
residency they go to Florida they don't
lose their
residency uh so each case is very very
different and I think different
legislatures might adopt different
policies and I think as we all know the
body that we shouldn't be mentioning and
I shouldn't have mentioned it and I
apologize uh might have very different
ways of addressing their membership than
size any further questions
I have one oh go ahead representative
Hopson yeah thank you for taking my
question uh just I don't know if you
mentioned this at the beginning of your
testimony and if you did I apologize but
where does this information come from
who decides that this is the purview of
the Attorney General or what the
Attorney General should that's beyond
our perview because that's something to
do with the Attorney General's office I
don't know how the attorney General
finds out what the Attorney General
finds out nor should I because as the
chair rightly pointed out that is a
matter for them and their investigative
staff and whoever calls their tip line
and however that
works I specifically omitted to put in
how the Attorney General would find out
because that's not my business I did
want to make it so that um the Attorney
General had to have probable cause to
believe that this was true before they
uh referred it to us because I don't
want the Attorney General to have to
deal with you know some person who calls
up and says oh by the way uh that that
was not my purpose it was only when
there is a situation which the Attorney
General believes Rises to probable cost
which is a pretty uh well defined
statute uh standard I should say and and
um so that seemed like a good line as
complaint uh my question is a little
different um although it does um concern
the Attorney General I guess or or how
the bill was
drafted my question would be what would
um what is meant to occur by the
Attorney General providing that
information to the people that you've
mentioned
um versus a registered letter sent to
the people um from whoever has that that
same
concern there are two different ways of
notifying us that we might want to make
inquiries into the situations of our
members uh there's nothing here that
prevents somebody who is concerned from
uh reporting it in different ways uh but
the real concern that I had was that
delicate balance for the Attorney
General's office uh between
their requirements of a criminal
investigation and our need for the
information so that we can do our own
investigation so that we can make sure
that we are following the Constitutional
requirements that our members live in
their districts because our constitution
says that when you're not living in your
District you're no longer a
representative and you know it's not oh
I can leave base and come back and tag
and I'm safe that's not what the
Constitution says so um there are any
number of other ways that this house or
the Senate might find out about an issue
or a possible issue uh but this one I
thought was particularly delicate
because it's very clear that the
attorney general has to walk a very fine
line but
between that which is the duty of the
Attorney General's office and that which
is the duty of the general
court uh thank you um is there any
concern on your part about um
simultaneous
investigations I don't think so because
um again we each have our own Duty under
the Constitution and um those should be
separate ours should come from us theirs
should come from theirs um and that's
what separation of powers is all
about thank you rep
cable thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um we it's it's
very clear that the the general court
acts acts on it it's not clear that we
have to investigate it so my my concern
would be on the on Dual investigation
that doesn't seem to be necessarily
where our part should be but after
investigation then we're the ones that
would act on that on us the the member
and residency and that sort of thing and
the AG would have on on the criminal
side but it seems like the AG would be
more apt to be able to investigate on
both matters and then report back
afterwards the issue with that is there
might be a situation that
arose sometime in the
future when the Attorney General might
be investigating something for a very
long period of time and might come to
the conclusion that there was no
residency and might report that to the
general court and a member who had not
been a resident for a long period of
time might have been voting on bills
that that member was not entitled to be
voting on and that would be contrary to
the Constitution of the State of New
Hampshire so it is incumbent upon us as
a
legislature when we know that there
might be an issue it is incumbent upon
us to determine what steps we are going
to take and that may or may not include
investigation it may or may not include
somebody deciding to hire a private
investigator it may or may not be includ
included simply talking to the
legislator uh every case is very
different but it is up to us to make
sure that we are upholding the
Constitution and I know that everybody
in this body takes that responsibility
terribly seriously we may not always
agree on how it how it happens but we
all take it seriously and the
Constitution is very clear on this
matter thank thank you
uh seeing no
further one quick question rep
kiery thank you for taking my question
and I'm sorry to do this but here comes
the stupid one who does our
us when these issues have Arisen they
have been dealt with differently by each
legislator each legislature leg
legislature uh so in one case there was
an investigation by this
committee um in other cases you know
um the other case I was involved with
wasn't actually decided by the general
court because it was a matter of whether
somebody could appropriately appear on
the ballot so it was decided by the
ballot law
commission uh but it's
um the procedures that have been
followed have been generally a matter
for the speaker in the first
instance um generally in consultation
with the minority leader and using the
expertise of the clerk and at that point
you look at the facts and decide what to
do and of course as always is the case
if the members of the body as a whole
believe that the speaker is taking
inappropriate
action they can certainly take action to
correct the speaker in the direction
that the speaker is taking so it is it
is a power that's reserved to all of us
usually delegated to one or two people
or to a particular
committee thank you um I'm assuming
you're responsible for removing the
fiscal note by
Amendment no
I I have nothing to do with fiscal notes
all right no worries someone will fess
up to it
uh what my thing says is when completed
the fiscal note will be forwarded to the
house clerk's office but I cannot
imagine how there would be a fiscal note
to a bill that simply requires somebody
to write a letter or send a
transmission uh
saying I have probable cause to believe
I didn't even work required that they
tell you what the probable cause was
that representative Weber no longer
lives in her district and then it's up
to the house to figure out what to do
with that information we'll find out um
thank you very much for your
testimony um thank you for the
opportunity I have no other speakers on
this
bill um so with that I will close the
hearing on
1629 FN or not not um and find out
more and with that we can move on to
because we're P our a lot of time to uh
House Bill
1152 um relative to
creating enabling the mental health flag
to be flown at the State House welcome
the prime sponsor representative McLean
um for three minutes welcome
Administration
right right you're all set
representative mlan thank you Mr chair
uh so thank you Mr chair and honorable
members of the legislative
Administration committee philler record
my name is Mark mlan representing
Hillsboro district 15 which is
Manchester Ward 8 and I'm here to
introduce HB
1152 which would add uh the mental
health flag uh to the statutory list of
flags that can be flown at the state
house uh one of the things that I do
want to stress is that unlike the P flag
um this bill
um you know States explicitly that uh
the mental health flag will only be
flown at the discretion of legislative
leadership it's it's a may be flown not
a shall be flown which is different than
the PW flag which shall be flown so it
basically allows it to be flown at a
discretion and uh the the reasoning
behind this was a year ago a work
colleague of mine whose daughter-in-law
Works in uh the mental health field and
who will testify later um he approached
me and he said look you know um May is
coming up May is mental health month and
um you know my daughter-in-law was
wondering if the mental health flag
could be uh flown on the 1st of May to
kind of open up mental health month so I
went and I approached uh the chief of
staff with the request and he came back
and he said it's not a bad idea however
no flag can be flown at the state house
unless it is on the statutory list
because you know we we have we we just
have requests every single day so it has
to be something that's on the list that
you know the whole body of the
legislature agrees and there's consensus
around it so I told the news to my
colleague and of course he was
disappointed he went back to his family
and they were disappointed but I think
everybody understood the wisdom of not
being not allowing every flag to be uh
flown it really needed to have broad
support otherwise you know you could
maybe you fly the NRA flag or something
you know you really need to have
something where you have a lot of
consensus but as I thought about it upon
reflection I really thought that going
forward and and highlighting issues
around mental health is something that
it is has a lot of bipartisan support it
is certainly something that is timely
and if anything was worthy in a
bipartisan way of having consensus to go
forward to be added to the statutory
list um it's the mental health flag and
I think you know that's because
everybody at at some point either in
themselves or somebody in their family
um have been touched at some point by by
mental illness in my own case it was my
mom when my sister was born when I was 5
years old she had a complete mental
collapse broke down became a prisoner of
the house she couldn't even go down to
the fire heightland that was too far
away so
basically not only she became a prisoner
of the house but the entire family
became a prisoner of the house and it
was something that we all kind of went
through and I didn't get to play with a
lot of friends but I did get to hang out
with Bob Barker and you know the prices
right and and everything like that so it
really was was limiting but the whole
family kind of felt it um later on you
know when she was finally able to get
health and and understand that what she
had was severe
agoraphobia you know it had a name we
were able to attack it and she was
slowly over time able to to recapture
her life and she could come down she
could visit me in New Hampshire she
could visit my brother in Texas and the
quality of life in her final years was
much better um and I know that many of
you folks probably have your own story
so um long and the short I think that
allowing the flag to be flown at the
legislature I don't think mental health
is a controversial issue is and it would
demonstrate to the people of this state
that we recognize the severity of the
issue and we understand that it has tend
ruls that go into um a lot of other
issues such as homelessness substance
abuse suicide things of that nature and
it would I think show that the
legislature um is visibly committed to
to having a role in ending it and so I
hope that you'll look forward you look
you'll look upon this legislation
favorably and give it a favorable
consideration and that's my testimony Mr
chair
thank you representative mlan I think
that's the first time I've ever heard
Bob Barker's name mentioned in
legislative
Administration um with that uh willing
to take questions if there are any yes
Mr chair yes um do we have
jot can you turn on your microphone
please thank you I kind of
want I'm wondering what would happen if
you put the American flag at half flag
the flag pole isn't tall enough and the
bottom flag if you add that flag on the
bottom it's going to be Dragon well um
the the the bill says the flag may be
flown so again that's just a discretion
of leadership the bill also explicitly
states that the flag will be flown in a
position that is subordinate to every
other flag and that includes the P flag
so it would be flown beneath that so um
if
uh something was going to be uh flown at
half mass for example um that may not be
the time to do it or perhaps under the
circumstances of what was behind it
maybe it would be flown that would be at
the discretion of uh of legislative
leadership how they would pull that
off representative Richards thank you uh
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um the in line four it says may
be displayed above the state house and
conquered um are you open to um the
potential of
other flag polls on State House
grounds um it's my understanding that um
it's already possible for it to be flown
at other areas in the State House
grounds I don't think you need I don't
I'm don't quote me in this but I don't
think that there is a uh a statutory
requirement for it to be flown elsewhere
um so that we would prefer it to be
flown from the dome but I think it can't
be flown and you can maybe double check
Mr chair
um uh I don't I I don't think that there
is a requirement for other flags on the
grounds to be listed in statute I don't
believe but I'm not certain I can get
back to the
out representative sellers thank you Mr
chair so we're looking at line six here
as well it says the flag uh shall be
flown immediately
below the flag of the United States so
you got a contradiction I think going on
here because the lower it's it gives an
order but but then in Roman two it says
if a state flag or other flag will be
flown of the on the same Flag Staff
meaning that's the same Flag Staff as
the United States flag the order from
top to bottom shall be the United States
flag then the state flag or other flag
you know which would be in this case the
state of New Hampshire the P flag than
the mental health flag so um if other
flags are flown Roman 2 very clearly
states um the order of
precedents representative
followup yeah thank you Mr here one
other question is so this is one flag
out of we could have hundreds of flags
we could run out of space on the pole
and space in the number days in the year
what are we to
do again though I think think
um
this in order to have a flag
um achieve statutory approval it would
have to go through the entire
legislature so um you would need to have
strong consensus as to this is something
that merits um is worthy of that so for
example you know you might you might
have you know motorcycles of America who
are a great organization um but if they
were brought before the legislature
would there really be enough consensus
within the legislature to say yeah I
mean that's a that's a fine flag we like
those folks but do we really want to
give statutory approval to something
like that so I think what I'm asking the
question that I'm asking the committee
is is the issue of uh mental health and
mental health awareness does it go high
enough up on the bar that it would Merit
that approval because you're right um
but I believe that the legislative
process will act as a very effective
filter and the question for you folks is
does this meet that measure I believe it
does and I hope you will as
well
good followup uh representative Richards
in the physical issues of the flag poll
the L L of the flag pole and the number
of flags and the increasing days of half
staff days um that I have witnessed in
the last six years I'm doing square
footage math and I'm asking the question
of all of us in the
committee if we were to say as I would
want to say that this does
Merit um that statutory there would need
to be a fiscal note
because there would be a physical have
to be a physical potential change at the
top of the State House dome for the
I
I'm I'm unaware of how much room is left
on the flag pole itself so um if this
was to pass into law um then maybe that
would be a consideration that would have
to be reviewed um but I I to be honest
with you I don't know how much room is
left on the flag pole
so I think we're good right um
appreciate your testimony uh we have two
other pink cards and probably more
questions thank you very much thank you
Mr
chair
we do have
bet
yeah no um we do have pink cards from
two people that I think know each other
um the Jessica and Jennifer kovic if I'm
saying that
correctly we're not going to do flight
you we have testimony with the flag in
it welcome to legislative Administration
um you've asked for two minutes and
three minutes so we'll see where we go
much hello thank you for having me um
I'm Jess kovic um I'm a graduate student
in the CR uh clinical mental health
counseling program at Southern New
Hampshire University um I am also a case
manager with the ACT team at Riverbend
Community Health as part of their
Community Support Program but I'm not
here today to represent Riverbend or
Southern New Hampshire University I'm
here because I want to end the stigma
surrounding mental illness because
mental health is Health uh when people
are diagnosed with cancer family and
friends walk to the person's side to
support them mental illness is almost
invisible it's hard to
see and until someone speaks up and asks
for help when people are diagnosed with
a mental disorder such as anxiety or
depression our friends our family they
just don't understand snap out of it
you're not pushing yourself enough
you're faking you're doing it for the
attention imagine asking for help and
you got that
response would you reach out again
mental illness is treated like a death
sent sentence that is
contagious our n our natural supports
disappear and we were are left alone to
suffer imagine if these things were said
to someone with a broken leg or a better
example would be someone with diabetes
since it's pretty invisible to the
outside you're not pushing yourself get
up you're faking it you're doing it for
attention
yikes um just because you can't see it
it doesn't mean that someone isn't
suffering with the right support such as
counselors prescribers family and
friends a person suffering from a
diagnosis can live a full and meaningful
life because mental health is Health the
origins of this flag began with the
Jones family they created the Pete
Foundation after the Beloved Pete took
his life at the age of 23 it was a day
of tragedy and disbelief that so many
families around the world have endured
they decided to invest their efforts
towards ensuring that no person would
have to suffer silently in the way that
Pete did it struck them that Pete was
only able to convey the depth of his
pain in a letter that he left
behind I have given these flag pin to my
clients and we use the colors to gauge
where they are one day my client will be
like I'm yellow today I I'm so happy and
then another day they'll be like I'm
feeling a little dark green today but I
know it's not forever the colors of the
flag have meaning the green represents
the color of mental health support and
varying shades of green and yellow which
represent coming out of the darkness
into the sunlight I wear the PIN on my
jacket as a reminder I get approached
daily by strangers in the community that
ask about its significance I draw
attention it draws attention because we
are all acutely aware of these small
gestures of support for something that
have a deeper meaning now imagine what
impact it would have flying above our
state housee it must be important
because mental health is Health thank
you
thank you anything to add uh my
testimony is a little bit different I'm
Jennifer kic I am a member of the city
council here in conquer but I'm speaking
as a resident but more importantly my
role in the community has been for many
years to lead the downtown history and
culture day for Capital Area student
leadership the greater conquered Chamber
of Commerce and any other organization
that wants the best free tour going of
our state capital part of the tour that
we give nowadays since 2017 includes the
John Gilbert winet statue that resides
across the street from this building
John Gilbert wet as you know was a
governor here in the state of New
Hampshire during the Depression he was
moan most known for handing out 50 cent
pieces to people that were homeless or
were suffering from the depression with
lack of income so that they could get a
cup of soup he would hand away his
jacket he would hand away his hat
to help others during World War II he
was the ambassador to Great Britain uh
Britain and he worked side by side with
Winston CH
Churchill when he returned to the United
States after the war he started the
Social Security Administration and one
evening in
1947 he took his own life and for more
than 60 years we covered all of his
worldwide accomplishments because of a
single moment in time when he was
suffering from depression and thought
there was no way out of the green and
into the
sunlight we we honor this man today
because we finally have gotten to a
point in our society where we can
recognize a moment in time does not
define an
individual the collective efforts of
both sides of the house and the Senate
and the governor supported the stat stat
of John Gilbert weet because we wanted
to send a greater message to our
community which was we're all here to
support each other and you're not going
to be buried under one moment in time so
I would hope that our legislators on
both sides will come together for this
issue to raise the mental health flag
and stop hiding what needs to be out in
the open to help as representative mclan
said those people that are suffering
from drug
addiction um any mental health dis
disorder it could be PTSD even from
those that are
pmas or served our community there are
so many people in our community that
need to just know there is help here
available and we are here to support you
thank you we we're glad to answer any
questions that was a remarkable
committee see I have one yes
um the flag um a who pays for it how
does it get here um is it privately
owned is it uh is it a trademarked um
item and and what does it
do being on the flying over the State
House versus anywhere else or any other
type of project that makes mental
illness
more available to us I can answer part
of that so with the Pete Foundation it's
not trademarked or anything like that um
it ALS they also will donate to any
state that wants to fly it above their
state house um I believe in the handout
there's a picture of it flying over the
state of
Kentucky um and then what was the third
question so the other part is that um
here in the city of conquered with the
support of Riverbend the coalition to
end homelessness and your state hospital
they flew the flag or displayed the flag
not everybody had flag poles at their
location
they did that last May for us because of
this effort to go through the
legislature to ask um the legislator to
fly at the State House So within the
city of conquered because this is where
we reside we reached out to our Network
to have them at least start spreading
the word so that we could do that also
in a conversation with our city manager
um there is an application process if
you wanted to display a flag down Main
Street so if we had mental health Flags
um it is an application process there
are multiple organizations that already
sign that application year-over-year and
there is no space for us and so this is
the direction that we came in we think
that the state house um being more
prevalent and having that higher voice
across the entire State sends a much Lou
louder message than just the city of
conquer great thank you very much for
your help we have a late entrance uh
question here thank you Mr chair
representative was curious now about the
flag is it in National internationally
known as far as the way it's designed
and everything it's world it's
worldwide good the mental health flag
itself is a dark green this is a takeoff
on that that actually shows the shade so
that people that are suffering from
mental health can designate to their
their mental health workers their um
psychiatrists their psychologist their
psychoanalyst here's where I'm am and
now it provides an absolute measure of
you good anyone else seeing none thank
you very much for your testimon thank
you and I have no other pink cards
indicating anyone would like to speak on
this
topic um with that I will close the
hearing on House Bill
1152 um Mr chair can I just note that
there's some buttons at the end of the
the table here for all of us to take if
we'd like to also take a button do we I
just noticed I'm right down here in case
you couldn't seeag is that what I yes a
folks
thank you Mr chairman may I um
distribute copies of what I'm going to
give
you
it
fine
so I am sorry that we're at the end of a
long day for you but that's okay you
don't have a flag though right we don't
have a flag all right on on what I am
attempting to do is to let a legisl
study committee fashion uh a home
and a method of
choosing research
projects that would
be uh most useful to the legislators
I've suggested that there be a group
like the one that deals with
um
um um with
the
the I'm sorry I forget words sometimes
today now
um
yeah uh that it decides which of various
uh departments are going to be
on picked um to get a uh analysis of
their um
functionality and I'm sorry I'm
forgetting that word right now but um
and it consists of Republicans and
Democrats I'm
suggesting equal Republicans and
Democrats so that there would always
have to be agreement on these things um
but what it is for
is to
employ data and economic data analysis
within the legislature to chart out the
probable impacts of major changes before
we commit to them
um and there's a side issue being from
the Ways and Means Committee on we
have a couple of us in a bipartisan
agreement that there should not just be
static
analysis uh to create Revenue
estimates that we need some way of
trying to look into the
future
and we have the Department of Revenue
Administration which I thoroughly
approve of using static analysis to make
Revenue estimates but these estimates
are based on confirmed data sets some of
which are 2 to 3 years old
our most important taxes uh are
estimated that way because the business
taxes have to go through
audit before they're confirmed and so
the numbers are two or three years old
that they are using on they then make
their best guess of how far off their
estimates may be and uh in times like
this the estimate ranges are kind of
broad
extremely Broad
and
on then they do a very good job but I
feel that having a second look at this
through multivariat longitudinal
analysis would improve our committee's
work and likely reduce the major
surprises we have when recessions or
growth spurts are cor
occur um we have a member of RA and
means that that's been there almost as
long as I have Jordan oler who is
continuously bringing up we need to do
Dynamic analysis and this is actually
pretty close to what he's talking about
but it's based in an economic
methodology that's been developing since
the
1950s
um I want to take you back about 15
years to the first time that a push was
made to spend money to provide dental
care for lower inome adults in New
Hampshire it took about 15 years to
pass because and we had two arguments
going on uh one of them is that it costs
too much and we have no idea whether
we're going to get our money back in the
future um the other one was that we are
keeping people on the public D because
their mouths are rotting out they
smell um they in in the situation a
number of adults find themselves in who
began life in poverty and and with
difficult without any Dental Care
whatsoever um it's one of the big things
that keeps them from getting jobs that
will support themselves and it's one of
the big things that keeps that section
of our labor force out of the labor
force and at this point we need as many
people as we can get in all levels of
jobs so
um
the the question is which of these is
happen and there's another one that we
are facing right now
which is if we invest more money in
child care and it's going to need quite
a lot of
money then um is that going to give us
enough more people in the labor force
on Prosper as much as it has been
prospering in the
past
uh when
uh and what kinds of child care if we
just had child care that would leave a
cou leave kids in somebody else's hands
while both parents go work
um how much would we get out of that if
we if we provided appropriate preschool
preparation for kada 12 so that the
children could hit the ground running
when they get into regular
schools
um how how much would that do is it
worth what we'd have to sacrifice in
other areas in order to pay for that and
these are both kind of long-term issues
that we may be arguing about within
ourselves and with each other about for
years before like dental care we finally
bite the bullet and do it
um I'm a socio
economist I both taught economic
research methods and I experimented with
their Tools in my pre pre-legislative
career which was 25 years
long I'm now that's why I forget things
I'm getting
old um multivariate analysis has been a
major part of the economist's toolbox it
allows the users to weigh a number of
possible factors influencing an outcome
such as greater net revenue and decide
which of them are most important to
creating that Revenue American
economists began working with
multivariate analysis in the
mid-50s 1950s but for many years they
were severely limited by their data they
simply didn't know how to quantify a lot
of the factors that do influence the
results uh as computers progressed and
as the economists began to incorporate
the work of other social scientists and
to quantify the factors they found
important their results have gotten a
lot
better um they can't predict the future
completely nobody can but they're doing
better A lot better at it than when I
was
young uh we have a longtime user of
multivariate analysis here in the
Department of Employment Security his
name is Brian godlo for a long time he
was he is a very strong Republican by
the way uh for a long time he was in as
a so working as a solo operator and
doing um analyses for various lobbying
groups and for um businesses and such
and I've always been impressed with his
insights he's now working with a model
that was set up over 40 years years ago
uh when Regional economic models Inc
otherwise Remy was
created The Economist that started that
model is still there and they have
been improving the model for 40 years
it's quite impressive it's used by state
governments from Utah to Massachusetts
to help them to decide how to make their
economy enies and governments more
efficient and more serviceable to their
people and they are here
uh but I did say help them decide
there's always politics involved in what
any state decides to do and this is only
one contribution to that no matter how
sophisticated the model is there will
always be factors not yet considered
that can upend it uh the group that
created the model advises its clients of
this fact and provides an outside view
of the results that we are likely to see
five 10 or 20 years ahead if we make a
certain change now or we don't make
it uh members of uh that group are that
are present are Dr Peter
evangelicas and Chris Judson who is um
at Kent tell us about the administration
of Remy I'm using Remy because it's the
only one I know that I really
um and have ever been close enough to to
respect uh there may be others and
that's why the bill is written so that
it would require uh if it
goes comes through this committee and
gets a legislative study committee and
creates um a
a
um a request for a bit bids it will have
probably more than than one bid but
uh I Remy really has the longest
reputation of any and the most wide uh
uh National reputation of anybody that
that um I've
seen also our state's best public data
analysts Phil slon from the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute and
former representative Doug Hall who
created the first professional and
nonpartisan Economic Policy Institute in
our state it fell apart
uh for some fairly
difficult personal reasons about 10
years ago now I think
uh and the New Hampshire Center for
Public Policy studies which was widely
used within the legislature to
understand uh the facts behind what we
were arguing about while it was still in
existence um they are here both here to
testify unfortun Brian gtlo told me he
might have to be at
work and it sounds like that's where he
is so
on I thank you very much for listening
uh I would like if possible for this
bill not only to be passed but to go out
to um to the legislature fast enough
that we and try to get it to the finance
committee so that was going to be my
first question if you're willing to take
questions yes um my question was
um why write this as a study committee
and not with your experience in budgets
um as such why not just create um a line
item
for a proposal um to
to grab bids and I'm assuming what
you're trying to do is create a Remy U
to to something like an inh house how
how well re they will explain how Remy
works but essentially please don't I
hope not they ad they
advise uh people selected by the body
that is employing them uh to uh that are
from here that someone would be working
here on using the Remy models and
advised by the national group and the
group in Amherst
Massachusetts and uh in in uh the
factors that over 40 years they have
found pertinent to particular
problems uh and but before we get to
actually the value of
the the service the the process
itself um I want to know the the U the
nuts and bolts of why you've created
this the the way you have
including um the the
extensive um laundry list of people to
be on this committee when it sounds like
what you want you already know exists
and why you didn't just write it as a
bill or or um some kind of a procurement
to to put it in place that's my I've
discussed this in several places around
conquer and um one of the places was the
LBA and the lbo
said people will buy into it
more if they can help write the
structure M and frankly also on their
variety of places it could be put I
would not want to see it in the
executive unless it was well protected
because every new governor
upends the the its own
office and so you're seeing this as a
legislative office I'm seeing this I
would like to see it as a legislative
office but they said you better let let
them have some more involvement in this
well and that gets me to my second
question or maybe longer um why why you
didn't have a legislator be the chairman
commission I can't remember at this
point that that I did I would it merely
says that the members of the commission
are going to elect a chair person from
among the members but but that makes
them one out of uh I don't know um six
or eight at least people um so if you
want this to be a legislative process I
would have thought you would have had
the legislature be the
chair you wouldn't be adverse to that I
guess I wouldn't be adverse to that a
legislator is going to be a Democrat or
a Republican and I'm hoping to make this
to totally nonpartisan numbers are
numbers don't know right um any further
questions
from okay um well let's hear from from
our uh you have picked
um Chris and Peter to be testifying
together is that correct yes yeah great
since there are two welcome to
legislative Administration if you could
step step up and introduce yourself and
tell us where you're from and all that
fun stuff um and keep it non-technical
that would be even better we do have a
yep apolog just send some around that
way oh these are this is
just supporting information uh with a
case study from the Texas legislative
budget board on how they Implement a
similar
process
right precisely and Chris Judson manager
at Remy uh I also accompanied by Dr
Peter evangelakis who will provide the
majority of the testimony today but we
do agree uh our goal today is just to
inform you on how models like ours or
are utilized uh by the majority of of
legislators and legislative bodies and
and similar types of of
organizations um
and happy to answer your questions uh
you and yes uh Peter evangelo is also
with Remy I'm our senior vice president
of economics and Consulting um so I'll
I'll keep it pretty brief and and
non-technical uh I just want to share uh
basically you know some of our
experiences with clients um who you know
who work with uh these these tools um
and I think uh a representative Al me
said it well when you know it's
important especially with uh with major
pieces of of of legislation but even
potentially with smaller ones to have a
good idea of the pros and cons and how
they weigh out against each other and
that's what our our clients value uh our
clients include uh you know legislative
bodies Departments of Revenue budget
offices uh we're uh we have we're
represented across Most states so we
have kind of a breadth of experience
across many different types of
governments um and I just wanted to
highlight kind of a few different uh
topic are areas where um I think this
commission would be interested to study
further uh and our experience there um
so I'll say you know one you know one
area obviously fiscal policy tax policy
you know um would certainly be you know
you know is a very important piece uh of
you know you know you know kind of
legislative uh you know the legislative
toolkit you know fiscal policy
understanding what the impacts of
different tax polic policies are changes
in tax policy is very important uh we
were involved um in 2018 and into 2019
with uh Arkansas uh we actually on
behalf of their um Bureau of legislative
analysis or sorry Bureau of legislative
research um we did a study uh put
together a number of fiscal notes on a
variety of personal and corporate income
tax proposals um that we understand were
later adopted in some form or another
over the next few years uh and so we
were brought in to not only to run the
study but I was uh uh brought in to
testify in front of their legislative
task force to speak to the results to
help guide their
deliberations
um there are um also a variety of
clients who look at you know kind of a
more specific issue of of tax credits of
of All Sorts so we have clients uh for
example we did uh uh work with uh
Louisiana um you know my my Consulting
team did a study for one of our clients
there looking at their quality jobs
program uh looking at B you know
incentives for certain types of
businesses and basically understanding
what is the you know what are the
benefits in terms of jobs and additional
Revenue versus you know what are the the
costs to the state in terms of offering
uh and we were able to find uh kind of a
balance point where um you could make an
assessment on both the economic
benefit and cost as well as the fiscal
benefit and cost um we also have uh
clients up in Washington State uh The
Joint legislative audit and Review
Committee um who are tasked with looking
at a you know a wide variety of tax
credits uh you know they use the model
in-house uh with our support uh and
they've looked at uh you know they've
used the model for you know well over a
decade looking at a wide variety of tax
credits and trying to assess
uh you know which should be maintained
which maybe should be retired uh things
of that nature so trying to be uh
accountable to the
taxpayers um a representative Aly also
mentioned uh Child Care um you know
there have been a couple of studies I
wanted to highlight one was looking uh
this also happened to be in Washington
State uh a client of ours looked on
behalf of their Department of Commerce
at uh uh a policy of of offering
subsidies for for child care and looking
at the obviously the benefits of that in
terms of Labor Force participation um
and you know business you know the
ability of businesses to retain their
workers uh versus the cost to uh you
know to provide the subsidy um we also
had a client in Mississippi do an early
childhood education study uh drawing
upon a wide literature trying to
understand what were the long-term
Workforce impacts versus what were the
upfront costs and and how to balance
those um and I'll just mention also
there's been a variety you know I know
that housing is an issue here and and
everywhere in in in in the country um
you know certainly a constraining factor
in terms of cost potentially in terms of
Workforce if you can't uh find places
for workers who want to come and work to
to to live uh you know we've done uh you
know we and our clients have done a
number of studies looking at um for
example if we were to look at different
uh zoning or development regimes what
would be the impact in terms of uh you
know additional uh you know kind of
additional you know the kind of the the
construction piece of it but also more
widely uh the ability to bring down cost
of you know the cost of living which is
uh you know going to be you know not
just beneficial for folks in the state
but it also may be a driver of of in in
migration into the state um can can I
ask um yes inter interrupt a bit of
course I I can see the kind of projects
that you're working on and I understand
the idea that um weighing the pros and
cons and and and assigning values to
them sure what um those clients that you
mention do they hire you for that for
those specific projects or do they um
have
inhouse um and and your brought in to
just um confirm what they already
thought um the the bill here is to try
to create it seems to me a
situation of having a permanent
Department do these
individual um
analyses is it not true that there are
uh groups like you that could be
purchased for um for specific projects
as they come up here so Mr chair so I
would say most of our clients um do use
the model themselves they have a team uh
that takes many forms uh depending on uh
the the the resources and Staffing that
they have but generally most of our
clients will operate at in-house uh and
we are the software provider and we
provide uh extensive support in terms of
advisement But ultimately those clients
are running the model themselves and
doing the analysis themselves we are um
as you know as part of my title I do run
our Consulting practice it's a smaller
part of our business but in certain
cases um you know we are brought in as a
third party um by either uh sometimes
clients who have the model themselves
sometimes clients who don't otherwise
have a relationship with us to do a
particular study so um there are
instances of both but I would say the
vast majority and certainly um the the
the type of client that this um you know
that that might be studied here we
generally have the model in-house and be
you know have a team running it with our
support um from the outside would would
that team inhouse be
comparable um I'm not sure if you're
familiar with our
LBA organization our legislative budget
would they be um I don't know if that is
the kind of team that you're envisioning
or is it something that we are not
familiar with in in our current
makeup uh to to the best of my
understanding um I mean perhaps
representative omy could speak a little
bit more to this but I I would say I I
don't I don't think it would be you know
I think it would be a fairly
standard um you know team you know that
is uh you know often you know a non
Artisan team that is just being you know
being asked to consider bills um uh and
kind of offering an evenhanded
analysis is it um and I I don't mean to
monopolize this if anybody else has
questions here
is is this um I guess my question would
be
um you've
seen um various legislatures around the
the
country is it a process that re uh the
types of bills that come up um and
you've listed several that you've worked
in different places
um I guess it does justify an
entire inhouse group rather than
Contracting with someone using your
model on specific projects is that right
I I would say generally yes uh because
is you know especially uh it offers more
flexibility for example during a session
if issues are coming up um and in
certain cases you want to be able to
turn around an analysis fairly quickly
but also there may be a wide variety of
issues over the course of a year that
want to be that you would want to be
looked at um and hiring uh a firm such
as ourselves or comparable uh firm to
look to work individually on each of
those analyses uh you know you know may
is likely to be less cost feasible um
and and may offer a little bit less
flexibility than having an in-house
team
around we are but humble
men because I give me a little prefer
here before the question because I've
got to I've got to frame this so I can
understand this
right
with with having clients and what I'm
seeing here with the testimony Utah
Massachusetts
Arkansas as
examples Massachusetts has a state debt
of$ 77 billion Arkansas's State debt has
tripled since 2000 Utah's local debt is
$17
agencies not using what you're offering
them correctly or is what you're
offering them not
working because
I'm not
seeing how if this is a model that is
going
economic holistic view right how the
states that are using this are going
deep deeper and deeper and deeper and
deeper into debt that that's what I'm
trying to figure out here so are they
are they ignoring what you're doing is
it they're not using it broadly enough I
mean how how is this how is this
relationship functioning with what
you're you're doing to actually being
successful because in those three states
they're going the wrong
way sure thank you so I I would I would
uh couple of responses one one is you
know we work with clients in in the vast
majority of States so those are three
but we work with with clients across the
board um I I would say also you know
modeling is you know we also have to be
humble as as modelers uh we you know we
cannot predict the future we're just
doing our best to understand uh what is
you know what are the most probable
outcomes um so that is not to say that
every analysis that's done by any model
is going to be totally accurate there
may be
deficiencies um but we are you know in
terms of what we offer um you know the
you know the model is uh as
representative Aly mentioned it's been
developed over many years based on in a
peer-reviewed uh kind of AC academic
literature um it's been it's been looked
at no model is perfect uh you know we we
we stand behind it um I think you know
also I'll say you know you know we're
asked to look you know the the model is
being asked whether it's us or the teams
at the various clients um you know
they're they're looking at particular
issues um it it may be worth looking at
kind of wider issues as well um because
certainly um you know the issues you
point to are of concern um
maybe uh you know but the purviews maybe
haven't allowed them to to look at those
issues sure um not along the same lines
though I mean as far as I can see it's
the relative debt of the individual
company uh
country states thank you
um may have completely nothing to do
with with their work that's where I was
going with my next question so so it's
not entirely fair to the accusatory tone
um we all we're trying to do is find out
whether this is something that um we
should take to the next level and study
here that's all we're trying to do so my
other question that that you didn't
answer was are you finding that when you
are providing your services that these
government because ultimately you don't
make the decisions right the legislators
those bodies make decision you're a tool
that's used in part of that process are
you finding that there
ignoring or or not doing what you're
offering properly is that is that a
common problem for you guys or is this
something where when you come in and you
do what
you're projected to do that that's
embraced by the clients or the states
that bring you into to do that do what
you do you see what I'm getting at yes
um I I would say we offer our clients
our counsil on best practices and we we
make sure that they're trained and aware
um when when we are brought in to work
on a particular project we will always
follow those best practices um but
ultimately as you said we are a tool I
cannot speak to whether our clients are
following or not following our our our
guidance uh I would be speaking out of
turn I don't really know um to the best
to the best of our knowledge we feel
that we offer good advice and that our
clients are receptive but that may not
always happen but it it's hard to know I
can't speak to
that if I may each state operates a bit
differently so sometimes when they're
asked to do a dynamic fiscal note some
states will say it needs to have a
static fiscal impact one way or the
other positive or negative of 10 million
some states may say 50 million 100
million so they're not necessarily
running the analysis on every single
piece of legislation it needs to be
typically a significant enough uh piece
of legislation or or sometimes through
uh audit committees associated with a
legislature they may go back on like a
biannual basis in review recent
incentive programs and and so yes it is
a tool to to inform policy makers um but
not every piece of legislation uh you
know current nor past may may be
evaluated thank you hey uh represent
um representative walls uh you have a
question thank you very much thank you
for being here and thank you for your
testimonies uh just a quick question we
heard previously that it helps to take a
second look at what our LBA is doing are
you looking to complement the work they
do add to what they're doing or what how
would you how would this go along with
what we're already
doing yeah I I I would say um I would be
more comfortable deferring that to
repres of all me just I I don't want to
speak on her behalf in terms of the
vision but what I can say is that you
know um a a tool like ours would be
useful for whatever work is being done
in this realm um but uh I wouldn't want
to step on any toes
uh very nicely said um representative
nutting Wong um so after listening to
Pearson I was trying uh representative
Pearson I was um
thinking um what I would what's like
kind of confusing me right now I guess I
don't really know where I'm going with
this
um I would love to have like a model of
like what we do now and what would
happen if we chose your model is that
kind of what you do right now or that's
what you're
offering if it was money um I just so I
understand I think what what we're
talking about is rather than our static
view of where we the snapshot of where
we are now for for big items um when
we're talking about them through Ways
and Means and
finance this is a more longer
term um model I hate to use the word
model but this is um evaluating it over
a longer period of time rather than the
snapshot okay I was thinking different
VAR and so it's it while it might be I
think through our um and I
representative Aly would probably be
much better to answer this but while
it's maybe connected to what LBA does on
a static basis with our fiscal
notes this would be much more
extensive
um if if it was that we had this service
in house um I'm not where I'm headed is
whether there is an a middle ground that
isn't a
full-time operation that does
longitudinal
studies but also not static if there are
projects that we would have that would
be able to be used and hire you know
subcontract someone out to study this
particular bill this particular
thing than have a um an in-house
247 service to use and maybe that's what
representative Aly is intending to be
one of the topics of conversation from
this study commission I think that's how
I'm wrapping my my head around this
further
questions
um I do you have any comment I guess on
what I just is that seem fair uh yes it
it does seem fair are there there other
firms like yours that um have or how
many other firms are there that have
their own model that would be
um utilized by the that could be sitting
here if rep Aly had contacted them how
many how many what's the world like for
you as competition
so I I would say um and I I welcome you
know I welcome you know kind of that to
be a topic of inquiry I would say in in
our specific area it's it's quite
limited there are other firms that do
economic and fiscal impact analysis uh
there are a number of them that are also
kind of of the static variety um you
know where you're getting more of a
snapshot uh I'm not aware of um kind of
a perfect substitute for what we offer
in terms of dynamic fiscal analysis uh
but there there are other firms who work
in this space generally okay thank you
anyone um I I think I interrupted your
your um Talk are there other items you'd
like us to be aware of
before uh uh I think I was just about to
wrap up anyway I'll just say um in terms
of kind of the you know in-house versus
bringing in you know hiring I would say
both are both um obviously both are done
we see both done I think it's just a
matter of what you feel the frequency is
uh of needing that kind of analysis if
you if it needs to be fairly on a
regular basis then I would say having an
in-house team is preferable if it's
every once in a while then you know
bringing in a firm such as Remy or or a
comparable firm uh would I think be just
fine as well I think that would work
well so uh but it does I think your it
sounds like your understanding is is
good of the next steps here and I would
imagine that would be a discussion for
the committee thank you any other other
points no from the other side of the
table no thank you I think your
understanding uh is is sound and
consistent with what we have in mind
great well thank you very much for
coming I appreciate it very much and I'm
sorry for the weight no problem thank
you very much um do you have a
thank you gentlemen thank you very much
thank
um okay um could you please in introduce
yourself and welcome to legis yes Mr
chairman thank you and um uh yes I'll
introduce myself because I'm here to
strongly support this bill the way it's
written to set up a
commission um I was a member of this
house in the late ' 80s and uh early 90s
I served four terms three terms on the
house finance committee when I decided
not to run again U the committee at my
retirement party gave me literally a
100-year old crystal ball that had been
used in many seances because what I had
been doing in that committee was trying
to focus on the future and what the heck
is this decision we're going to make in
finance here going to mean four years
down the line six years down the line
I'm going to look into the future and
you're going to describe who you are and
and why you're here who you are right
now would be good yes Douglas Hall I
live in Chai Chester I'm just here
representing myself because of my prior
experience part of which I
described also when I left the
legislature the uh speaker and the
Senate President offered me the job as
the legislative budget assistant and I
turned that down and at some point with
if this commission is set up I'd like to
talk to them about why I turned that
down because there are certain positives
and certain negatives about having any
kind of future forecasting being done in
unfortunately
the the way New Hampshire does long-term
planning is with a two-year time
Horizon that's long term sometimes it's
even shorter than that and that's
because of the election cycle for every
state elected
official and in reality we should be
planning much longer ahead than that and
know what different policy Alternatives
might
mean Walter Peterson when he was
governor set up a process to do a
10-year plan it didn't last after his
term uh when I was in the house uh
legislation passed that required a state
development plan economic plan and um
that plan was done in
1988 1990
1992 94 96 6 1998 and
2000 RSA
9A requires this
plan it has not been done since the year
2000 um I contacted the people in um the
department who were responsible for it
they said there were efforts in
2003 2007 and
2011 which didn't proceed due to the
lack of funding and buy in from the
governor's office at the time
this is where we are with any kind of
planning in New Hampshire and if this
commission is set up and all you're
being asked to do is set up the
commission so that then some real
discussion Could Happen about what where
should this commission be what should be
its
charge I would love to talk to that
commission about some the things that I
know that would be helpful to them in
coming up with legislation for a
subsequent time to deal with this um and
so that's essentially all I want to say
I I think it's really important to set
up this commission and if you do do that
if it passes through your committee
through the house into the Senate uh and
becomes law I will be there to talk to
the commission thank you thank you uh
willing to take questions yes
yes any questions from the committee
representative sers yeah thank you Mr
chair I just want to say you perfectly
put because uh I think the commission
will find out is it something we we need
is it something internal is it something
external that we can use so I I think
this is you got to do the commission or
the study to find this out it sounds
like it would you believe I I would I
would believe that uh and I would
mention that um that there's the fiscal
policy in
and you'll hear from them uh there's the
Cary school at UNH that does good
demographic work um I'm not here to
support any particular contractor or any
particular way of doing it I'm just here
to support the idea we need the
commission in order to try to do
something about long range planning in
this
state Mr Hall can can I ask uh your
opinion then on the makeup of of the
commission um i' I'd leave that to
representative Aly um you know if if
it's going to be in the
legislature in the end and the the you
do need to have legislators as part of
that commission but there are other
possibilities and I think there's some
arrangement for that within the
membership that's been specified but I
would leave that up to representative
Aly as the sponsor to suggest any
changes to what's already in there I'm
fine with it however the membership
is um okay how about uh the duration are
you are you okay with the idea that um
they would be able to issue their final
report by November 15 of
2024 yes it shouldn't take very long if
they now I would have to say if they
meet once a month and it doesn't get
passed until June well maybe not but if
you set the deadline in in November
that's fine then maybe they have to meet
every two weeks in order to get the work
done so I'm fine with the deadline but
if they don't actually get together very
much um they're not going to make the
help last but not
least um I got the philli part um if you
could if if you could introduce yourself
alone welcome to legislative
Administration thank you very much I
really appreciate the opportunity to
speak before you um Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Phil slon
I'm the research director at the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute NH fpi
is a nonprofit nonpartisan independent
policy research organization based right
here in conquer we examine the state
budget state revenue the state economy
and the economic security of granite
Staters um we don't have any positions
on pending legislation so we don't we
don't Lobby I'm not here to provide
anything more than informational
testimony what I wanted to provide you
with today is a very high level summary
of the publicly available research on
state revenue estimates and estimating
methodologies that other states use um a
lot of the in-depth research a lot of
the uh um academic research in
literature around the revenue estimating
methods of States actually was conducted
in the wake of the Great Recession of
2007 to 2009 when a lot of States had
trouble estimating revenues through that
time period and New Hampshire was one of
them um because it's a difficult Dynamic
economic environment and that's common
that it's difficult for states to
estimate Revenue in those so a lot of
the existing research focuses on that
time period and on processes um
associated with Revenue estimation
Revenue estimating processes do vary
considerably by state forecast might be
produced by the Executive Branch the
legislative branch a combination of both
or groups of academics or economic
Consultants may be called in to uh
produce Revenue estimates some more
recent data that we have which is
actually from the National Association
of state budget officers they surveyed
States in
2021 28 States used what was called a
consensus forecasting method which is
creating binding estimates that are
produced by a group of legislative and
executive branch officials sometimes
including outside um economists and
other experts as well uh that was 28
States 12 States including New Hampshire
had competing forecasts from the
executive and legislative branches and
then 10 states gave sole responsibility
for forecasting Revenue to the executive
branch and uh in that same survey 18
states reported having a council of
economic advisers of some form so uh and
New Hampshire was not one of those
states there were 40 States including
New Hampshire where the executive branch
budget office provided Revenue estimates
in New Hampshire the correlator to this
would be the budget Office of the
Department of administrative Services uh
and the revenue estimates that come from
the Department of Revenue Administration
that the house Ways and Means Committee
and Senate Ways and Means committees
look at as well as the other um agencies
that collect revenues whether that's the
insurance department the Lottery
Commission Etc 37 States not including
New Hampshire um had the budget office
play a role in economic analysis so
performing some form of economic
forecasting that was in 37 States 19
States also not including New Hampshire
had a budget office that assisted with
demographic
analysis and older survey data from 2008
so unfortunately this is quite a bit
older but does provide a little bit more
depth um does give us some insights into
the technical methodologies that those
States used so 27 states of 40 that
responded to this question reported
using a simple trendline analysis for
Revenue forecasting that included New
Hampshire in 2008 27 States not
including New Hampshire used time series
modeling 32 states used linear
regression modeling 16 States used a
simulation and 14 used a private
consultant and New Hampshire was only
included in the 27 states that used the
simple trend line analysis a 2011
literate r view indicated that at the
time there was not a single method of
estimating Revenue that was considered
Superior from the others uh so the
method the the research was a little
agnostic on the method at least at that
time but the research also suggested
that well consensus Revenue estimating
methods were not necessarily better
combining Revenue estimates were so
producing multiple sets of Revenue
estimates and having many different
viewpoints that then led to a combined
set of Revenue estimates that was a u
that was a valuable method so on the
third page of the packet that I just
handed out to you with my testimony one
of the pieces of analysis that I wanted
to provide to today is how have our
Revenue estimates done so since State
fiscal year 2000 from St fiscal year
2000 to 2023 our estimates were about
$75 million low each year that's about
3% low each year um the absolute value
of the error so that that averages you
know the pluses and the minuses are
average out um if you look at the
absolute value of the error the
magnitude of the error was about
$14.7 million each year or 5.1% error um
so again you know not not massive we're
not talking 15 or 20% error but a 5%
error if we remove the last four years
out of the average error because it's
been very difficult to forecast if you
look on the graph you'll see that it's
been very difficult to forecast revenues
since the pandemic struck if we remove
those four years then the average error
is 31.1 million or 1.5% and the absolute
error is 80 million or
3.6% now that 75 million does not
necessarily represent the entire state
budget impact it may you know Sound
small in the grand scheme of the general
and education trust funds but um and in
scheme of a $6 billion year state budget
or now $7 billion year state budget but
those General funds can also be used to
match Medicaid dollars for example so
there's a there's an impact that goes
beyond just the amount of Revenue
projection that was um in error so to
speak uh so you know if those dollars
were used to match with Medicaid then it
would double the amount of federal
dollars double the amount of dollars
that come into the state budget because
of those Federal matching funds so with
that I'm happy to not pull any more from
this document that I gave you but this
document is also online on our website
at nhp.org and I'm happy to take any
questions the committee may have thank
you for your concise testimony um
anyone
have applicable questions I think I
think we're all at the end of the day
here um I appreciate your time no um as
questions come up um I'm assuming that
we can reach you either through uh
representative Aly or directly yes you
can reach me directly my contact
information is on the last page at the
bottom of the page on the packet that I
just provided excellent well thank you
very much for coming I appreciate it um
representative Wy you would like a wrap
up a quick wrap
up emphasis on the quick part yes well
actually it wasn't a wrap up I wanted to
point out that state
debt is our
bonding
and uh some and the way to look at that
debt is the relationship between the
amount of debt and the amount of
Revenue that we have to pay it off right
but it's long-term debt that is put into
building the infrastructure of the
state and um I was a little upset
because uh I know the senior senator
from Utah through
ncsl who is incredibly well respected in
the financial area because they do such
a great job of this uh Massachusetts I
won't I won't talk about much I have uh
I have one more question for you if you
wouldn't mind um with your experience of
the of the bills that come
through this um
Sausage Factory in a in a term what um
what percentage or how many um would
be likely to be um benefit from a
longitudinal
study that would uh be a very subjective
thing I think that's what I'm asking
that's on that's
why we've got for the performance audits
which is the word I was kind of pull out
of my brain before and we've got a group
of people that make decisions on whether
one should be done or not and why I
think that that it should be a
group that has to decide with four
people on each side to uh which um of
the projects
that that ought to be looked
at and it would also be limited by um
we're talking about at this point one
person there is one person in Employment
Security that is working with this and I
think he may have a little help help on
some stuff I'm not sure but I do know
that he doesn't if he isn't there to
answer the phone in his
office uh not answered so
on
the the we would be depending um in the
early days we would have to find the
right person to be doing this I would
love it if Brian golo would move over
but um I'm not sure how many more years
he wants to be in service uh all right
um well if we can't if we don't have an
idea of how big a a problem this is um
or well or
opportunity that's the that we could
expand it to be twice the size of LBA if
we wanted to but I don't think that's a
New Hampshire idea I don't think so all
right uh thank you very much for
bringing this forward um with that I'll
close the hearing on um on this bill
1219 um we are meeting next Wednesday
next Wednesday um digest all of this
because we we have votes next week um
for the Republicans we will probably be
caucusing um prior to that so that we
emails uh yeah executive session is in
the
afternoon hearings in the morning thanks
very much any other problems questions
comments that need to be no good thank
much